This is Jocko podcast number
27 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Okay.
I knew a simple soldier boy
who grinned at life in empty joy,
slept soundly through the loan,
some dark and whistled early with the lark
in winter trenches, cowed pen, glom
with Krumpes and lice and lack of rum.
He put a bullet through his brain.
No one spoke of him again.
You smug faced crowd to with kindling.
I who cheer when soldier Lads March by
sneak home and pray you'll never know the
hell where youth and laughter go.
That's a poem
called suicide in the trenches.
Bye Siegfried Sasoon.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Siegfried Sasoon was decorated for
extreme bravery in world war one on the
western front.
He was nicknamed Mad Jack for his nearly
suicidal exploits against the enemy.
His brother
was killed in action
in the glibly campaign.
He was eventually sent to a hospital
to try and recover mentally from what
he'd been through while he was there.
He wrote a little letter that was called
finished with the war plus soldiers
declaration
where
he came out and said,
we got to stop fighting the war like this.
I'm speaking for the men that are on
the front lines in the trenches being
killed,
and even after that
he was promoted.
He returned to the front again.
He was a wounded this
time by friendly fire.
That's World War One.
Yeah,
and while Siegfried
Sassoon tells us to pray,
we will never know the hell
where youth and laughter go.
Yeah,
I do not agree with that.
I want to know when I want everyone
to know and understand and to see
the hell,
the darkness
that crushes youth and laughter.
Then taking us on this voyage into dark
tonight is a man by the name of Bob
Hoffman that if you look him up,
you'll see he's a very accomplished man.
He was obsessed with health and
fitness and he became a businessman.
He was the one of the founders
of the York Bar Corporation.
If you ever lifted weights in your life,
you've used York barbells at some time.
Nope. He's often called the
father of modern weightlifting,
but interestingly,
what you won't find much about
him is his military service.
You don't see generally that he was
awarded the Distinguished Service Cross,
the Silver Star, the purple
heart, the French cross of war,
the French military metal,
the Italian war cross,
and the highest Belgian military award.
The order of Leopold.
Okay.
You just don't hear that about him,
but that was a piece of his life.
Okay.
He did write about it.
You wrote about it in a book,
which is called,
I remembered the last war
and let's go to the book.
Few
people have been able to learn much about
what actually took place in the front
line,
fighting of the world war.
They have often asked about the war and
it found few veterans who could talk
about it.
One of the chief reasons for this is
that they had little or nothing to tell
about the war.
Approximately 4 million men
were in service during the war.
Half of these went to France and of these
half a million, we're near the front.
10 men are required behind the
front to keep one man in action.
Service supply truck drivers,
hospital workers, ambulance drivers,
guards in the bass ports,
the replacement and casualty camps.
Many thousands of military
police, artillery, signalman
aviators, mechanics, and endless more.
Our division lost more men than any
other former national guard division.
More Monday,
more men than any other organization
except the first and second regular
divisions.
Our regiment lost more men than any
other regimen over our division.
Our battalion,
more men of any of the three battalions
in our regiment and our company.
More men than any other
company in the battalion. Yeah,
we had men who never saw a
German who was not a prisoner.
Some of our men were cooks, top sergeants,
company clerk supplies sergeants,
buglers, signalman kitchen police.
The men who carried up the ammunition,
the rations, cared for the wounded
and advanced stations buried the dead.
Many one liaison men carrying
messages from company to battalion.
They fired and were fired at as we
fought in towns, woods and hills,
but seldom saw targets at which they
fired bombs and shells were dropped on
them. They suffered from gas
and most of the horrors of war,
they were killed,
but they weren't actually at the front.
Okay.
Men who were trained as I was scouting,
patrolling observation,
sniping who led patrols,
reconnaissance or combat advanced guards,
captured prisoners, put a gun out
of action, held advanced posts,
served as suicide squads,
and we were being attacked were the men
who actually saw war and most of them
are dead
while 125,000 American dead and France
are not so many when divided among the
million men who were at or near the front.
It is a tremendous percentage when it
is considered how few of these men were
doing the fighting.
Okay.
More than 250 men in our
company alone or killed.
Okay.
More than the original strength of the
company lost their lives in France.
They can't tell you the story.
I was phenomenally lucky,
so I will tell our story.
We'll try to tell you something
of what happened over there.
There have been more books written by
other men who were better writers than I
more fitted to place what they
saw upon the printed page.
Okay.
But I don't believe a book about America's
participation in the war has been
written by a man who spent days,
weeks,
and months in intensive fighting at or
in front of the front as my comrades and
I did.
There is nothing particularly glorious
or beautiful about this story.
I've told it as well as I could,
but have been able to give you only
a faint idea of the conditions we
encountered during the five worst days
of any unit of the American arm army
experience in France.
The five days of our battle of fizz met.
Okay.
You could fully appreciate its
horrors only if you were there
never was a group of men harder pressed
by superior forces of the enemy or more
ill equipped to fight off those attacks.
Then we
no artillery support during most
of the fighting, no trench mortars,
no hand or rifled grenades.
Just a moderate amount of pistol,
rifle and machine gun ammunition,
no food,
proper medical attention
or the opportunity to bury
the dead are men in that
battle,
the handful who held the front lines
covered themselves with undying glory.
The telling of this story will give a
better idea of what we did in France and
other books than other
war books I've seen.
It tells the unvarnished truth
about how we lived, slept,
hiked, fought, and died over their
scores of my friends.
The men I had lived with,
trained with, fought with,
had come to liken, admire,
died in the woods in France.
It was only by a series of miracles.
Amazing escapes that I did not die
to that I am here writing this book,
okay?
I was young then 19 years of age at
the time of the battle of the are gone.
Okay.
I had been too busy to live and because
I had not found what a fine place the
world can be,
I did not mind particularly dying.
I had no actual fear of death.
Okay.
21 years ago when we fought
the battle of the Argonne,
I had 32 ugly Boyle blood boils on my
body from eating a diet consisting mostly
of meat and bread for some weeks boils,
which made me swear more than I
have all the rest of my life has.
I constantly scraped them on the rocky
ground while digging a new hole to
protect my body.
Each time we halted.
Yeah,
I had French itch and copious
quantities of mustard gas,
ugly burns,
which still leave their scars.
12 bullets left their mark on my person
or my equipment in the first short
battle.
Okay?
I was one of 32 men of our 250 strength
company who marched out of the battle of
Fizz.
May.
I was the only man to return of those who
followed me on five patrols that I led
in one day in the Argonne forest.
Okay.
I hope through this book
at least partially to show
the gruesome side of war,
barred from the waiving of flags,
the bugles bands,
the cheering to show at
least part of the ugliness,
filth, dirt, evil,
a morality and stink of war.
Okay.
Be sympathetic but remain aloof.
Be Strong,
prepared to protect our own
country against any nation
or combination of nations
which may attack our homes, our
democracy, our American way of living.
Okay.
If our country was attacked,
the first hour would not pass before
I would plan to enlist and millions of
other Americans would be in just as much
haste to protect our wonderful country
and our American way of life.
So that's
okay.
How he kicks this book off,
kind of burning through the intro there,
and I really liked the point that he
made when he broke down the numbers that
how many people go to war,
but how many people are actually
fighting and it's a big discrepancy.
There's a, it takes a lot of people to
get bullets to the guy on the front line,
right?
It takes a lot of people to get that
person transport it to the front lines.
It takes a lot of people to
get to keep that person fed.
It takes all kinds of
logistics and support just to
just to get that guy through
the door of a building where the enemy is,
and I've talked about this before too,
in Iraq, there was places in Iraq where
there was basis in Iraq where it
was basically like being in America.
They had restaurants and Starbucks
coffee and Mcdonald's and Burger King and
they had pools and movie theaters.
I mean it was crazy.
Is it where like you mentioned like
Burger King for example, do they,
does burger king the company
kind of make a deal with,
you know the government and be like,
hey, we want to supply Burger King? Yes,
I'm sure it actually,
I shouldn't have said Mcdonald's.
He was usually a burger king.
They must have,
will be the ones that
had the deal at the time.
So Burger King was there
on base and you would,
we would travel though to outstations
where there's some army unit.
This is on my first appointment,
traveled to some outstation where there's
some army unit live now in the middle
of nowhere,
just totally desolate.
Some Marine Corps unit live in in the
middle of the nowhere eaten Mrs Everyday.
And like there was a group
we were working with, one,
I wish I could remember where
they were to give him some credit,
but they were out there.
They were on one Mre a day,
which Mras and meals ready to
eat. It's a, it's a not a very,
not a very good way to live off of.
And these guys were out there living off
of one MRE a day and age. You feel bad,
you know, you go out. We stopped that.
We, I think we had to stop at their base.
We had to get some information,
gather some Intel,
they knew some targets around the area.
We went and talked to him,
saw how rough they were living and we
went out and hit our targets that we were
driving back to our big bass,
you know,
where we had good food and you know,
Internet,
stuff like that. I mean it's, it's,
it's amazing how good it can be.
And that's what,
that's what people,
some people don't realize about the
military as it takes a lot of support and
logistics to keep the guys on the front
lines on the front lines and not taking
anything away from those folks that are
doing that. Because that's a hard job.
And I've talked about this before,
those logistics convoys
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
those things were hardcore and horrible,
dangerous jobs to do.
And so I'm not taking anything
away, but if you want to say, okay,
who went out and hunted
down the enemy and got them?
It's a much, much smaller group of
people, right? So it's like individually,
yeah,
you got people who did that part of it,
but collectively it's just this
huge force, right, of people. Yeah,
it's a massive,
it's a massive force,
but it's even more extreme
because in world war one,
the lines were very clearly drawn.
I mean,
you had literally had
trenches in the ground.
And so if you weren't within range of the,
of the enemy attacks,
I mean maybe that gets some planes to you,
but you would,
you'd be living relatively safe.
And that's his point.
And then when you get a little
closer to the front lines, yeah,
you were going to get some
artillery bombardment,
but everyone had dug these
nice holes in these trenches.
So the guys that were actually
invading German trenches,
most of them are dead. Most of them are
dead. It's a small, it's a much, it's one,
it's one out of every 10 soldiers that
was actually going forward to attack.
And most of them are dead. I mean,
you could hear what he just said.
They took more casualties than the
strength of their, of their company was.
So they had 250 guys.
There was actually a thousand guys in
the company because they took so many
casualties.
That's why World War one is so horribly
disturbing and scary to me because like
I've said before, there wasn't a tactics.
You're your own tactical prowess.
One going to help you.
You're your own personal skillset
wasn't really going to help you.
Yeah. You were going to get up, you're
going to charge an and really, uh,
Bob Hoffman talks about
this and he was just lucky.
He was a great athlete and he trained
hard and he was constantly trying to make
himself better. I'm sure that contributed
to it all somewhat. But Hey, when you,
when he comes off the battlefield and
he'd been shot 13 times a one, you know,
in the knees, his bullet holes in his
canteens, he'd been just, it just,
that's just miracle. Look, don't.
So going back to the book,
he says,
we should bend all our efforts toward
becoming so strong that no other nation or
coalition of nations
will dare to attack us.
We should build the physical strength of
our manhood and womanhood or mechanical
equipment,
our navy in particular and our army so
that we can resist any form of invasion
in the future.
And I,
I put that in there because you're going
to see a pretty common theme in the way
this guy lived his life, which was to
be stronger, faster, better, smarter,
always trying to improve himself,
always trying to be the best
Bob Hoffman that he could be.
And obviously that's how we ended
up running a giant, you know,
Organization for weightlifting and fitness
and he actually took some heat for the
way he lived sometimes and here they were.
They were on the,
on the ship heading overseas,
heading to France or to England.
And he's talking about what it was like
for him being a guy that believes in
being strong and healthy and smarter
and trying to improve himself.
Here, here we go. Back to the book,
all sorts of men make up an army,
good,
bad and indifferent.
I found myself in lots of trouble.
I had been fond of study
athletics and work. Went home.
I didn't smoke,
drink to gamble or go out
with questionable women or
indulge in other diversions
that some considered to be manly.
Yeah,
there were men who thought that I was
a sissy because I did not have manly
habits.
This led to a great many fights
and I fought at one time.
I would have to beat every man in the
company individually to prove that I
wasn't a sissy.
I did get enough practice that later
enabled me to win the boxing championship
in my body weight class of our division.
This experience serve me well on the
Atlantic crossing for, I fought five,
three round fights in one day.
Someone had to do it
and the job fell on me.
So he was getting, you know,
for lack of a better word,
picked on because he was a goody two shoes
and the only way he was able to stand
up for himself,
which just to get his scrap on,
get his fight on the street
edge. Yeah. He was, uh,
he was an early day straight edge guy.
Yeah.
I don't think he had a,
the straight edge music going into his
head yet that might have helped them out.
So they get overseas and now
I'm taking you straight into it,
into them getting him, getting tasked
with, with their first mission.
Okay,
and here we go.
Was I thrilled the front at last when
asked by our captain if I wanted to go
with the platoon, I said, do I want to go?
That's what I've been a yearning
and aching for all these months.
When I was just a youngster, I would
read books telling how anxious soldiers
were to go into action.
I couldn't understand how men could
desire to go out and fight and die,
but it is something that grows on you.
You train and expect so long that finally
you become anxious to get into it,
to get it over with.
Time was short.
We went back to our companies on the run.
Our company was assembled and I briefly
explained that a platoon of 58 man was
to be selected and that we were to make
an attack with the French at six o'clock
that night.
My words felt like a bombshell,
a brief cheer went up from our company.
I asked all the men who wanted to
be first in action to step forward.
And like one man,
the entire company stepped forward.
Mandy did. Men who did not get to
go on this trip cried real tears,
a direct contrast to the lack of
volunteering for dangerous missions.
A few months later when
they had become war weary,
then they would go if assigned to
any task, no matter how dangerous,
but they did not rush in.
They became fatalists and said they'd go,
if they were chosen, they
die. If it was their turn,
but they weren't going to overwork fate.
Okay.
And if you,
that's perfect.
A comparison to the story that I tell in
my retirement speech where we had this
horrible situation going on in eastern
Ramadi and I basically said, all right,
whoever wants to go and
live in this worst area,
put your name up on that board in every
gap with their name up on that board.
And I'll tell you,
this is also accurate in the fact that
you fast forward two or three months into
deployment after we'd taken
casualties after mark had been killed.
And all of a sudden, guys, we're not,
and I'll use the exact quote he uses here.
They'd go to any task assigned
no matter how dangerous,
but they did not rush in.
They became war weary and
that happens to anybody.
Then I even saw that on my
first deployment to Iraq, we,
when we first got up into Baghdad,
everybody wants to go on every mission.
Everyone's all fired up,
but as time goes by,
you start saying, what are we doing this
mission for? What's this mission about?
Who? Who were you going after?
Fear starts to creep in.
Now let's get to the assault.
The French men were working like
mad with their trench mortars.
They kept shells continuously in the air.
At three minutes to six,
sergeant Felix walked along the pair of
Pitt informing all our men that we were
going over in a few moments.
I urged him to keep down,
not to make a target of himself,
but he disregarded my advice.
Finally,
as our watches,
which had been synchronized before
the pointed exactly to six o'clock,
there were whistles and commands
and climbing men leaving the trench.
All along the line,
the gunners who had been
working so desperately with
the trench mortars to pave
the way for us,
cheered and cried out to us,
evidently urging us to sweep
the Germans from the hill.
I just couldn't understand what they said.
Okay,
and soon we were in the thick of things,
bullets flying merrily.
By this time from the German trenches,
perhaps a fourth of a mile away,
I was hardly out of the trench
until some great force pushed me,
knocking me over for a
distance of perhaps 20 feet.
I didn't know what had hit me, but I
felt blood running down my right eye.
After that knocked down,
I forgot the line of combat groups
and we fought just as our ancestors.
Ancestors had always fought instinctive,
rushing forward,
stopping to shoot,
rushing again and shooting again.
Okay,
so that's like that's you're welcome
to combat. Oh, you're all fired up.
You ready to go get some cool.
Go over the top.
The first thing that happens to use, you
get shot, which is what happened to him.
He didn't even know it yet.
All Americans have a legacy which has
come to them from courageous fighting
pioneer ancestors.
The American soldier is a good soldier.
He has not had the centuries of
drilling to make his own individual self
subservient to the will
of the commanding officer.
He does not like to salute the brass
bar unless that lieutenant has a one,
has respect through deeds.
He does not like to be regimented,
turned into a mere robot.
He can think and act for himself,
and when a battle has
passed the initial stages,
he's the best soldier in the world.
This is going, it's again,
reminder, this is world war one,
and I say this all the time.
People in the military are not robots,
and I can't speak too much about
people from other militaries,
but clearly this was a standout fought
as an American looking at American troops
in combat. They, they're not just robots,
and one of the best things about
him is that they can think,
okay,
now here come a bunch of Americans
over on some Germans coming up on their
trench.
Perhaps the Germans were two startled at
the size and evident ferocity of their
antagonists to fight well for a minute,
but it seemed like a
group of big men who had,
who had met a lot of
boys playing soldiers.
One push and the Germans rifle was
knocked from his hand along frost,
and that unfortunate man had
reached the end of his life.
I can still see faces of these
men. They're evident. Terror.
Their astonishment at the number of men
who leaped at them from the grass at the
size and power of these men,
they're evident helplessness.
There was not time for them to surrender.
Okay?
They had jumped up with bayoneted
rifles in a moment or two,
it was all over.
Okay.
Now this continues.
Our advanced troops had passed me by,
I could see dead Germans laying here
and there right near me were two of them
close together. One of them was a big
older man with a Prussian mustache.
His hands still class for the point
in his stomach with a bayonet,
had gone in and been withdrawn.
The youngster lay all twisted up.
He too had been bayoneted and it seemed
that his bones were broken from the
strokes of the butt of a rifle.
A rifle is a wicked weapon when swung
by a powerful man and there were many
strong men in action that day.
It's, you know, you hear
about bayonet fighting,
okay.
But to think about it on
this scale where this is,
this is looking more like a scene out
of Braveheart at this point than it is
looking like a modern war.
People clubbing each other to death and
stabbing each other bay in that range.
The Germans weren't giving out,
giving up without a real struggle.
We had let her read a lot
about chained machine gunners,
but these men weren't chained and they
were fighting to the bitter bitter death.
Now that chain machine gunner,
this is like a rumor that happened.
The deep American's would here because
the Germans had a machine gun and it was
a big heavy sort of a medium weight or
heavyweight machine gun I think is a mg
Oh eight and and it was so heavy that
they put this big sling on it and on the
sling it was a made of leather,
but they had to reinforce the leather
with chain and so when they find these
soldiers dead with these machine guns
and the the chain would clip into their
gear. The rumor was that these guys had
just been chained to their machine goes,
you can't leave. You're just going to
stay here and fight to the death. Yeah.
Okay.
Our men were coming back
to the book are men.
We're constantly rising and falling.
Some of them never to rise again.
Our ranks were becoming rapidly decimated
and there were few of us still going
forward at this point.
I have never seen an authentic list of
the casualties of a company that day,
but I know this.
I never saw a single one of those 58
men of our company who went over the top
that night.
Again at the front.
I had been hit several
times once on the left knee.
Once on the right knee, either bullet
could have left me crippled for life,
but both glanced off the bone leaving
only a scar which is noticeable to this
day.
One grazed my arm leaving a scar at
present an inch long and three quarters of
an inch wide.
I had a variety of feelings as these
bullets struck or scratched me.
The first which hit my helmet gave me
the same sensation as if I had been
pushing as if I had been
pushed by a gigantic hand.
The bullets on the knees stung luck.
I had been hit with a whip and the bullet
that cut through the arm and the one
which left its mark on my face
felt like a drop of hot water.
It hit me about this time the
battle would become very hot.
We fired at every enemy we could see.
And they were firing from every
direction from the front left and right.
And even from behind because we'd gone
so fast that we had not dropped the
snipers who were firing
at us from the trees
caught in the little
360 degree field of fire
by the way, caught in a 360 degree
field of fire after you've been shot.
What,
five times.
Okay.
We talked about lucky obviously better
to be lucky than good at this point.
It's crazy how he w w how he
described getting shot. You know how
you'd almost think that Dang you get shot.
That'd be so painful.
But when you're in the heat of things,
and I think it happens so fast that it
like your nerves don't pick up on the,
the, the destruction. It depends
where you get shot. Yeah.
It depends on where those rounds hit.
And I remember actually even here in
guys from Vietnam, guys from seals,
from Vietnam told me, um, one guy told me
a story that the first time he got shot,
they were out on an operation,
came back.
He was literally heading out to the bikes.
Are you actually,
you said he was in the bar and he realized
he was bleeding and you look down and
he'd been shot somewhere in the abdomen.
But you know,
obviously it wasn't that bad,
but he had been shot. Um, yeah.
And it, it can, it, you can,
you can catch a bullet in the wrong place
and it's game over or you can catch a
boat in the wrong place and you can just
take you off your feet or you can catch
a ball in the wrong place and
your arm won't move anymore.
Or they'll be massive amounts of pain
or you can catch a bullet in the right
place and it goes through and through.
It goes in and out very quickly, doesn't
hit anything vital. And you know,
you're just kind of lucky
as far as the pain goes.
You think, you know it's the
same thing. You're right.
Sometimes it goes through and through
and guys barely even notice it. Right.
And sometimes if it hits the wrong spot,
it hits a bone or whatever. I mean it's,
it's like a ricochet massive pain.
Like I hear stories about, um,
it's,
it's going to sound
kind of good tests,
but like grills will get stabbed in the
back or something and there'll be like,
oh,
it felt like,
I'm thinking of a particular story I heard
where girl got stabbed by an attacker
in the back and she was like, Oh, I,
it felt like he was just eating
me with his fist on my back.
And then I felt the warm blood going down,
you know?
And then later on they found out,
it's like, I don't know, it's weird.
It's like it happens so fast or
something combined with adrenaline,
you don't feel that the
destruction part of it, you know?
And it depends what it hits.
And it does depend on what it hits.
That's crazy sentence. Felt
like hot water that, you know.
Yeah. Actually I had a guy,
one of my guys got shot.
He was out, you know, firefight
going on and all of a sudden he's,
he feels the hot,
you know, the hot kind of dripping
down his back, hot liquid,
dripping down his back.
And it turned out he had just been shot
in the camel back in the camel camel
back. You know, those, they're
like thermoses, they're like a,
they're soft canteens you wear when
you're back and it was hot out.
So the water up and you started off,
he shot, he thought he got shot,
but it actually just
hit his game while back.
I remember my toenail fell off right in,
in training that I stubbed that on
a corner and I almost passed up.
So you kind of consider the destruction,
you know,
you kind of compare them.
It's almost like taking a bullet would
be less painful then ripping out echoes
toenail.
Well,
it was my toenail got ripped off and then
so it was jacked up for a few days and
then I stubbed that on the corner of uh,
I think it was like,
well you got a bunch
of nerves in your toes.
That's where he got fingernails
or toenails. And again,
the most important thing is
where, you know, what does that,
what does that bullet hit? What does that
blade hit? What does it do to you? Yeah.
Does it hit the, does it
hit a nerve or not? Yeah,
and the adrenaline because when
I got my tone, no ripped off,
he would hit at this weird angle where
it just peeled back my whole big toenail
and it didn't really hurt that much
because I was rolling, you know,
the adrenaline and stuff. But if I
just sat there and said, Hey Jocko,
peel back my toenail like that,
it probably hurt way more.
It would hurt way more
because you'd be in fallen.
Alright, here we go. Back
to the book. The for Raiders
of machine guns of any sorts
are targets for all rifleman's.
Their vulnerability in action gave
rise to the term suicide squad.
Sergeant Felix called to one of
the runners to bring him the gun.
The runner dropped dead as
he handed the gun to Felix.
We advanced the German third line
trench fighting desperately meanwhile,
and driving the Germans before us.
I had not reached any
of them with my bayonet,
but had been doing the deadly work with
my rifle as we rushed to the German
trench expecting to jump down into it
and fight hand to hand with the enemy.
We saw that we could not do this.
The trench was covered thoroughly with
barbed wire so that nothing much larger
than a hummingbird could get in.
We laid down outside the pair of Pitta
fire at close range. Someone shouted,
look out, there's a bomb. It went
off. It went right off in my face,
but all my parts seem to be
present immediately afterwards.
I saw Felix lying there sprawled
out groping for his pistol. I said,
what's the matter bill?
He couldn't answer,
but turned weekly to me and I saw that
half his face seem to been torn off.
I picked up the automatic rifle and
as I turned it into the German trench,
they got up and ran back.
I was the only one firing.
I saw many of them drop with a 60
shots a minute. I was pumping it down.
So I knew I was getting enough of the
enemy to make up for our men who had been
killed and wounded for a time and
there was nothing to shoot at.
So I took stock of the situation so far
back that they were hardly more than
specs.
I saw tiny men in blue dicking in.
It must've been all of a half a mile.
I knew that we should not stay
out here in such an isolated post,
but what were we to do?
I never thought for a minute
of abandoning the wounded.
So there we stayed.
The snipers far off in the wood.
We're still firing at us and there was
no way we could reach them or entirely
escaped their bullets.
I couldn't get into the trench,
so I call it crawled around
it well over into the woods.
Shell holes everywhere.
I saw for the first time what have it
could be wrought by shell fire at places.
The show holes were connected
solidly to each other.
The trees and bushes were shattered.
Men were blown up and blown up again.
They were in pieces.
It would have taken a Bushel basket
or a Gi can two of gather up all those
Germans for burial.
I admit that they were the finest
of soldiers after four years of war.
They fought to the death before we,
before they would give up a position.
They were so well trained that
it was second nature with them.
They had been regimented for so long,
but they never questioned in order put
up with all sorts of privation suffering
and we're cheerful through it all.
The majority of them were
in very good condition.
When captured it showed
they could take it.
I often wondered if our own men could
be as good soldiers after four years of
war.
All of us could not be brave.
Bravery is a sort of fixed quality,
something that some men's have,
some men have and others do.
Not.
Only physical collapse
or death stops the brave.
Some will be brave when they must win.
They like mother animal are driven by
this instinct of self preservation to
protect their own lives or
that of their offspring.
A man who naturally has
courage is fortunate.
It is the ability to control his mind,
to prepare it so that he feels nothing.
Courage is the product of physical
strength and mental strength. Combined.
Proper training will make
men more courageous and
certainly these Germans were
courageous,
physical strength and
mental strength combined.
That's where that courage comes from.
Back to the book,
I tried to do something for the wounded.
They were very cold by this time,
suffering from loss of blood. They
were lying there stripped to the waist.
I reached for the canteen
of one of the dead men.
There were two bullet holes
through mine and it was an empty.
Just as I turned a bullet from a far off
to the left toward through the flesh of
my cheek.
Had I not turned at that very instant,
it would have gone through my head dead
center killing me or sadly may me me for
life
little vote Shona who laid
there was just 16 years of age.
He was the first of a dozen youngsters
whose ages range from 14 to 16 who would
have listed in our company.
They had lied about their actual age,
uh,
neighbored with the appearance
of our fellows in uniform.
They too wanted to be soldiers.
Some of them lost their nerve before
they reached the front and tried in many
ways to get out of service.
The Spencer Brothers 15 and 16 years
of age were to be killed by shell fire.
There was no fear in
this little Italian boy.
He's talking about little vote Shona.
He'd always been a hot tea hothead,
wanting to fight with a knife,
fork or anything he could lay his hands
on when someone antagonized him a bit.
He was dashing forward with bayoneted
rifles in hand so fast when the bullet
which killed him,
which hate him,
that he lay out well on the Barb
wire covering the German trench
kids 1415 and 16 years old.
I don't,
I'm not saying anything bad about
our current state in America,
but I have a hard time picturing the
current brood of 1415 and 16 year olds
getting their trench warfare on
1415 and 16 years old.
Okay.
Face to face with the Germans.
Back to the book. I crawled back
and there was one of our men crying.
I asked him why and he replied that so
many of his friends had been killed.
I told him not to worry about the
killed that we had living wounded,
to be concerned about to get back,
that he'd better go for help
and stretchers and see if
we could not evacuate our
fellows.
I had no other thought then that I
should die as bravely as I could for my
friends or country or something.
So I prepared to sell my
life as dearly as possible.
In a surprisingly few minutes,
there came a crashing through the woods,
the sound of voices and a large
body of men came into view.
I lay,
still waited until they were close and
then jumped up pointing my automatic
rifle at them and it was
prepared to go into action.
I suppose it was a very startling
to have a dead men jump up for,
I certainly looked dead.
I pulled the trigger and as soon
as one man fell, the other roles,
the others all shouted comrade.
It's like holding up a train.
No one wants to be the first killed.
So a crowded car permits
a one man to hold it up.
When the Germans found that I had stopped
firing, they were anxious to surrender.
There officer was as nice and polite
as any headwaiter in a high class
restaurant.
Yeah,
he knew a little English and understood.
And when I told him to have his
men pile the arms in one place,
put their packs and another and make
improvised stretchers to carry back the
wounded.
Okay.
This all took her just a few minutes
and soon we were starting back.
So the tough Germans,
he ended up capturing a bunch of Germans
and he actually actually makes a funny
comment here
that he says that as he was walking
back with all these Germans that he had
captured,
a couple of the guys now helped him once
he got off the front lines and he says
that his award says that he had assisted
in the capture of 38 Germans and he can
see he's kind of upset about that cause
he did it by himself. He didn't assist.
He got the whole thing done.
Yeah.
And now he ends up,
because the wounds that he suffered,
he ends up in the hospital.
Then he starts having faults
and explaining what it's
like being in the hospital
and the people that
are in there with them.
Youth of all nations
seldom reckons the cost.
Okay.
They make the best soldiers because they
will go out and try to die bravely for
their,
as I expected and tried to do.
Older men are more cautious.
They have homes,
perhaps families positions
they know about life.
They usually know the folly of war.
They are careful and battles
are not won by being careful.
Yeah.
The impetuous youthful
soldiers are the best fighters.
That's why war will always take the
flower of the manhood of the nations
involved the strongest,
most intelligence,
most of useful of men.
Okay.
Now he starts talking about what happens.
He's again still in the hospital
trying to recover from the wounds he's,
he has his wounds obviously aren't as bad
as some of the other wounded that he's
in there with.
Okay.
Back to the book. When a man was
dying, they would move him out.
It was not,
it was bad enough for him to die without
his comrades who did not know when
their own turn might come,
having to watch him die.
Some of the men went out
screaming when they were moved.
The nurses would try and ease their
going by telling them that they were only
going to the operating room for minor
treatment or to the dressing room to have
their bandages changed.
The fellows soon learn to
observe whether the little bag,
which held their personal belongings.
Sometimes a helmet or
a coat came with them.
Yeah.
If it remained behind,
they could expect to come back,
but if it too was moved, then they were
sure that worst was in store for them.
Okay.
Some beg to be left there to die
with their friends around them,
not to be placed with a lot of near
corpses who were complete strangers.
The more pitifully wounded
did not wish to live.
They constantly begged doctors and nurses
sometimes at the top of their voices
to put an end to them.
Some made attempts to end their
lives with a knife or fork.
He became necessary to feed these wounded
and never leave a knife or a fork with
them
are blinded man who is suffering
greatly and did not wish to live,
had killed himself with a fork.
It was hard to drive it deep enough
through his chest to end his life and he
kept hitting it with his
clenched fist to drive it deeper.
That is,
I guess about as bad as it gets
when you have individuals that survived
combat butter and such a wretched state
that
no soldier killed himself with a fork.
Yeah,
they know what of one of my guys,
one of my buddies,
Ryan job, he, he got blinded the in
both eyes after he took around to the,
to the face.
And
it really does show you,
I mean,
I would talk to him on the phone when
we were still over there and just,
his attitude was so indomitable.
His spirit was so strong.
And I'll tell you something else,
he had been sent to at one point,
he was sent to the place where they have
the guys that have had traumatic brain
injuries,
who are having trouble with their thoughts
and with their motor skills and guys
that are in really bad shape.
And when he was there,
and I talked to him on the phone,
he spent about a week there,
Teddy told me, you know, hey, I'm
moving. I'm a, I think, I think he'd,
he'd already left,
but he said,
basically told them,
hey, get me outta here.
I don't need to kind of help with these
guys needs. I'm taken up someone's bed.
So even though he was blind,
and of course he was a tough bastard,
but I mean tough bastard or not,
he was blind.
I mean that's a game changer obviously,
but he still looked at the guys that
were wounded worse than him and was like,
Hey, I don't want to take up anybody's
bed. I'm good. I'll be okay. I can't see,
but I'm good. Did you say you
went to come back to oh yeah,
yeah, of course. Yeah. He,
he was like telling me,
just let me come back.
Let me come back and I can,
I can,
I can stand watch cause I can smell them.
And unfortunately he didn't
get a chance to go back.
So now there's a,
them,
the Germans had made a drive for,
for Paris and the Americans were
now involved in a counter attack and
Bob Hoffman is still in the hospital and
now the wound it start coming in from
this counter attack.
The wounded that came in now
were particularly serious cases.
Men who had been wounded
by tremendous shells.
There was much screaming in anguish
displayed by the solely wounded men.
Seldom
was it quiet at night,
man who's nerves broke would
be screaming all night.
There were many cases of shell shock men
who had had their maniacal moments when
they felt that they were still at the
front being subjected to shell fire.
They were out of their minds and there
was nothing that could be done about it.
But it made it most unpleasant
for the other wounded,
horrible cases of mustard gas.
We're everywhere.
Some of these men were blinded
and had to lie for endless days.
Would their heads covered with bandages?
Some of the men were able to walk,
sprayed a legged down the isles.
I was told that their testicles had in
some cases shriveled up like dry peas in
a pod.
They were certainly in a bad way.
So the mustard gas,
it
attacks the softest part of your
tissues, right? So your eyes,
your nose,
your testicles,
like anywhere where there's
moisture and softness.
And
on the 21st of July,
the doctors decide that he's
fit to go back to the front.
He gets on a train queue.
Imagine you go,
you fight this battle,
you get wounded and you come back.
You're watching guys come in that
are severely wounded, shell shock,
mustard gas, and then they say, okay,
by the way, now you're good to go.
We're going to send you back out to
the front like you think you got that
million dollar wound that we talk about
and a bunch of these episodes where
people say, oh, I made it off the
front. He goes off the front for,
I don't even think it's a month,
I think it's a few weeks and
now you're fit for duty again,
back to the front, back to the
front, back to the meat grinder
and he'd goes there by train
and a surprisingly short
time at about two o'clock
we were close enough to the front that
we had started to see the dead soldiers
of both armies along the way.
The American soldiers had been buried
hastily and holes they had dug along the
road as they were advancing,
but there were still many of
them laying in the fields.
I could see their khaki uniforms and
they're white faces as we passed.
There are two chief reasons why a soldier
feels fear first that you will not get
home to see his loved ones again,
but most of all picturing himself in the
same position as some of the dead men
we saw. They laid their
face up usually in the rain.
Their Eyes Open. Their face is Pale
and chalk. They're gold teeth showing
that is in the beginning.
After that,
they are usually too horrible to think
about. We buried them as fast as we could.
Germans, French and Americans
alike, get them out of sight,
but not out of memory.
I can remember hundreds
and hundreds of dead men.
I would know them now if I were
to meet them in the hereafter,
I could tell them where they were laying
and how they were killed, whether boots,
Shell, fire, gas, machine, gun or bayonet.
Yeah.
In the beginning we had a fear of
the dead. We hated to touch them.
Some of the hardest experience of my life,
we're taking the identification
tags from my dead friends.
The first dead man I touched
was Philip Becket ditch,
an Austrian Baker who is with our company.
I tried to save his life by carrying
him through heavy enemy fire and putting
them in one of the sellers
of the French houses.
He was shot in my arms as I carried him.
Yeah.
A few hours later I found time
to go round and find how he was.
He was dead,
stiff and cold.
Okay.
I had to remove his identification tags
and they slipped down between his collar
bones and the flesh of his chest.
They were held there and it
took an effort to get them out.
I thrilled and chilled with
horror has I touched him.
It was hard to touch
these dead men at first.
My people at home hearing of what I was
passing through expected me to come back
hard, brutal, callous, careless,
but I didn't even want to take a dead
mouse out of the trap. When I got home.
You had over there.
I buried 78 men one morning.
I didn't dig the holes for them of course,
but I did take their personal belongings
from them to return to their people,
their rings, Trinkets, letters,
and identification tags.
Okay.
You hear these days,
you know,
people will talk about seeing a dead body
and how that's a traumatic experience.
And as a matter of fact,
my son, uh, he has,
he found a dead body one down on the beach
and one guy fell off the cliff and by
my house I saw that in the news, but
right, right, right. And you know,
people were saying, Oh, you know,
you should, you should, you know,
make sure you talk about it with them
and make sure he's okay and all that,
you know, great. You're concerned.
But can you imagine, I mean,
you're just seeing dead body after dead
body after dead body, after dead body,
after dead body, after dead
body, it goes on and on and on.
Yeah, like that kind of, this kind of,
if you're in that environment,
sometimes it could,
you could have that kind of
desensitized, you know, feeling.
But I would imagine you would really come
to get you after everything calms down.
You know, like, like how he was saying he,
he didn't even want to take a mouse out
of the child dead mouse because it's a
reminder in this calm environment or
reminder of just all that death, you know?
But at,
yeah,
at the time it seems like they're
almost like there could be two kinds of
reactions to it where they either get
used to it or get tired of it kind of
thing. And then so if you get tired
of it, it was just way on your way,
on your way on you.
But if you get used to it,
it just gets less and less
impactful, you know? Yeah.
Well obviously they had to deal with it.
They had to detach from it. You couldn't,
I mean,
it's just like you talked to a doctor
that's been in practice for a long time.
Eventually they cannot get emotionally
attached to every patient as they had.
Or they would go completely insane.
They wouldn't be able to do the job.
And it's the same thing here.
Obviously you can't get emotionally
attached to every single body that he's
dealing with. But you can tell that
it leaves a mark. Yes, fully. And,
and you'd think that, I mean, the
doctors, the good little analogy,
but the thing that the doctor has,
and I was talking to Luke, you know,
Doctor Luke here, we're talking about it.
Um, jade asked him that question like,
it does it ever weird you out when you,
you know,
you're operating on somebody or whatever.
And what doctors get is this sense of,
okay,
so the not only the job,
but it's almost like working on a car,
cause you kind of know all of the little
working parts and you can fix them,
fused them together and boom,
it works. Now, you know,
kind of still there's that element of
thinking. Um, and then, yeah, sure.
On the other side it's a person.
And if you know the guy, you know,
it might even be more personal,
but in war it seems way more dark because
the guy's not supposed to be dead.
The, you know, the goal is
to live and to win the war.
Death is literally like the worst case
scenario for the person or one of them.
So when you see someone dead,
it's like man, it's not,
it's part of the job, but it's not the,
the, the outcome that you're, the goal,
you know, it's no part of the goal is
to die ever. It's like the bad part. So
it can't be substituted
with, Hey, you know,
that you can't substitute your thinking
in regards to this dead person with,
you know, part of being part
of my goal of my job, you know,
all I will say that, you know,
when you've got at least we had a,
we have a volunteer military
service and everybody that joins up,
okay.
No. So that's part of the
risk of the job. So at least,
even though that's obviously not the goal,
you know,
that guys have at least come
to grips with the reality that,
that that's what they
may face. Yeah. Fully.
Kind of like if you're a fighter in
the gay, uh, you know, getting knocked
out, seen a guy get knocked out or broken
leg or something like that, it's weak.
It's part of the game, you
know, but um, obviously way,
not quite as heavy as the war
situation. Yeah. So speaking of which,
back to the book,
here they are,
he's now just fighting and
he's with another guy named
Vaughn and Vaughn kind of
pokes his head up above this barricade
and start shooting and he's kind of
looking at it,
I'm thinking that seems pretty dangerous.
But he sees Vaughn getting away with it.
So he gets up there too and
starts shooting and soon
there they're firing shots.
And then back to the book here.
But after several shots each,
I suddenly saw Vaughn's helmet go
sailing down over the slight hill.
I looked at him and the entire top of
his head was off apparently a dumb dumb
type bullet,
one in which the lead had been cut so
that it would spread in the instant struck
during a terrific hole
in the object it hit,
had flattened against his
helmet or tin hat and had taken,
is taken off his head to a
level with his eyes and ears.
He had been kneeling and his buttocks
went back a bit his head forward.
And his brains ran out there in
front of me, like soup from a pot.
Yeah,
I did not fire over another wall.
The sniper had his choice to pick one
or the other of us for some unknown
reason. He chose Vaughn.
I'm here and he's gone.
Von Lay there for a couple of days.
Finally,
he was carried down and stored in the
room where we had the other dead piled up
like logs of wood,
but he had to have his
own place in the corner.
It was gruesome enough.
Okay.
The nerve strain of the
constant gas attacks was severe.
We were wakened up at every hour of
the day and night to stand too in
preparation for an attack
to prepare to move on,
or at least put our gas masks on,
but now they're getting ready to
do another assault.
One of the greatest barrages into history.
The war was being put over the earth
and the air constantly trembled with the
force of explosions.
Each flare would show us the
details of no man's land,
no man's land between the lines dead
men were laying everywhere in the most
grotesque positions.
Some of them lay as if sound asleep.
One man's head rested so comfortably on
his arm that I could not believe you is
dead.
Others had been blown to pieces several
times and some were just arms and legs
or torsos.
This night approach to
the front made us sick.
Okay?
As we finally found the men we were to
relieve, we were all thoroughly sick.
The ground was rotten with
tear and vomiting. Gas,
mustard gas too was all around.
War is bad enough without
the constant torture of gas.
Okay?
There was a constant cry for
stretcher bearers for the Red Cross,
the most diabolical screaming and
moaning that could be imagined.
Yeah.
Human beings lying helpless.
No way to fight back not knowing who
would be killed by the next shell.
It is hard to be brave at
night shelling at night.
Saps the courage from the bravest.
Everyone lies there and shakes only the
strongest can keep their right minds.
Okay?
It is on such nights as this
that men go out of their heads.
One will never know how he will behave
in such an ordeal. Some men weep,
other shake,
some standup nonchalantly,
apparently not caring whether they get
killed or wounded. Some tell crude jokes,
but mostly the men dig and dig.
Set is only the direct
hits that will get them
Grimley and during the torture,
that human being subject each other
to not knowing who will go next.
Okay.
We spent five days in that place,
which was popularly called death valley.
I don't know whether there was any
real object and staying in dying there,
but we were ordered into that
valley and there we stayed.
Yeah.
There were always a few maniacs around
men who had lost their mind through shell
fire and had to be overpowered and bound.
Okay.
Some men were buried alive and we were
constantly busy digging out the live
ones.
Okay.
Many would be smothered
before we could get them out.
At times we would have a group of wounded
and stretcher bearers making their way
up the hill. A shell would fall among
them in nearly all would be killed.
So many men were wounded,
wounded again,
and we're still under fire.
Sometimes we found two or three men dead
together and so badly mixed up that we
could not tell whether we got the
right parts in the right grave or not.
The men suffered and so did the horses.
Yeah.
One of my most painful memories at the
front was seeing a shell dropped near to
artillery horses.
The horses broke away from the tree to
which they were secured and galloped up
through the field.
One of the horses was hitting the abdomen.
It's in test is it's an
testings dropped out,
dragged on the ground and soon it's feet
were entangled and its own intestines
to the point where it fell down
and could not run any further.
Okay.
Hey, lay there with its head up for what
seemed like to be an endless period.
It seemed to be more surprised concerning
how it had become entangled in its own
parts than in the pain.
Yeah,
we were sorry that was so situated by
this time that it was difficult to put it
out of its misery. I think most
people when they think of horses,
you just think of a beautiful creature
running free
and now you have this image
for the rest of your life.
Okay.
There was intense fighting at a place
called surgey and the usual atrocity
stories.
We heard many of them.
They went something like this.
A two year old girl got in the way of
a marching column of German troops,
a soldier bay and edit it and
carried it away on his bay. Annette
children were slaughtered
for no apparent motive.
The soldiers tied up civilian prisoners,
prodded them with bayonets,
put lit cigarettes in their
noses and ears and shot them.
Eyes were burned out with red hot pokers
civilian snipers were tortured in every
possible way.
In Vimeo.
They had been spread eagled in the public
square or wrap would be placed under
an iron kettle upon the man or
woman's bare abdomen than a fire bill,
a top the kettle,
the victim was tortured
first by the frantic running
around of the rat on his or
her bare abdomen when it became nearly
smothered and terror stricken and pain
filled from the smoke and heat.
Then it would eat down through the body
of the humans living flesh to escape.
We found the dead body of a girl.
Her arms were nailed to the
door and extended fashion.
Her left breast was half cut away.
A young boy of five or six years of age
lay on a doorstep with his two hands,
nearly severed from his arms but still
hanging to them at another place where
the board of the dead bodies of a
man and woman or girl and the boy,
each of them had both hands cut off at
the wrist and both feet above the ankle.
Child of seven beheaded,
a whole family killed including a young
girl because the girl would not give
herself to the Germans
burn to death in their houses.
All the women violated the
entire German regimen, drunk,
et cetera.
The above are exact quotations from
the Bryce report which specialized in
outrages against women and children.
They are samples of the sort of
stories we were always hearing.
He goes on to say that he never
saw personally these things,
but this is the kind of things that
they heard about happening all the time
and they're getting ready
for another counter attack.
A court council of war brought the
decision that we would cross the bridge in
day light demand got ready to move and
we prepared to rush across the bridge
three or four at a time.
The ranks of every company
had been decimated and
probably our outfit consisted
of only four or 500 man instead
of the full strength 1000 men.
There should have been.
There were dead Germans all around,
but I could see one particularly well.
He'd been coming up the street,
passed one of the garden walls
and had been hit with a shell.
His legs were laying on this side of
the wall were lying there like they had
been taking from some gigantic frog
while on the other side of the wall,
the whole the shell made,
I could see the rest of his body.
He was a powerful appearing man in his
early twenties with a thick shock of
blonde hair.
His eyes were wide open.
He never knew what hit him.
About the middle of the afternoon,
the Germans tried another counter attack
and we helped the defenders behind the
barricade and in the houses
farther up the street.
By sniping from the second
floor of the houses we occupied,
we were prepared to stop the attack if
it had penetrated down the street to our
positions firing over the heads
of men behind the barricade,
we were able to assist in stopping this
counter attack the Germans to had their
snipers to cover the advance of their men.
I remember one who's firing very
carefully from a window in a house,
well up the street.
I took careful aim and he fell
forward out of the window.
During all this fighting,
the air was filled with dust
and with the fumes of powder.
They burnt our noses,
throat and lungs to such an extent that
we could not tell if gas was in the air
and it's this point,
they're trying to make progress and
they get caught in a horrible crossfire
flanking fire.
Okay
frontal fire is bad enough,
but flanking fire as suicidal men
were getting hit all around us.
They were calling for stretchers,
trying to apply their own first aid
kits on every side and some of them were
gasping out their breaths
to have come so far,
at least 4,000 miles and to have
their lives snuffed out so wantonly so
uselessly behind this wall
and the backyards of a remote
French village that the
world would never have heard of were
it not for the action which took place
there
and this
defense that they make of this village
kind of comes down to one final
situation that they're in.
They're holed up in their about
to be attacked by the Germans.
Okay.
Some gas had fallen which added to the
pain and bleeding of the wounded and
prove to us that no hell in the hereafter
could be greater than this manmade
hell that we were enduring.
Man.
Men began to go out of their heads shell
shocked if we could call it that or
just crazy from weakness,
strain suffering and
hungry hunger with all bed.
The death around them.
Yeah,
it was near the breaking point
for all of us who survived.
We would ask ourselves,
how can there be any more?
But there was more and worse.
The night wore on and the morning of the
fifth day was about to break the German
artillery speeded up again.
We knew that an attack was impending
everywhere. I looked for dead men.
There seemed to be no live men
around to man. The guns here,
they call them were shouted along the
line and many of the nearly dead men rose
up to man their guns behind the wall
that had become almost a part of us.
Wave after wave of Germans
were coming through the pear,
the pear orchard rifles,
hand grenades and machine guns,
but worst of all the flame throwers,
I could see the men plainly,
they had tanks on their backs and from
the ends of their hoses came great masses
of liquid fire shooting toward just
at a distance of at least 50 yards.
The smoke went far beyond us.
We felt that the heat would burn us up.
Every man able to fire concentrated upon
the men who were operating the flame
throwers. Almost immediately
they were put out of action.
Their tanks perforated and each
man's body a massive flames.
The flames leaped and shot into the air.
Voss was the attacks stopped by
the Germans own diabolical weapon.
Okay.
They suffered far more than we,
okay?
Never after that in the war
did we encounter that type
of flame thrower again?
They were real suicide
squad.
The man who operated those tanks were
sure to Sophal a terrible and quick death.
Okay.
It was a narrow escape.
There were just a handful of us left.
Okay.
What do we were relieved that night?
Yeah.
Had staggered across the river.
There were just 32 of us left.
Yeah.
Our companies on the line,
we're almost completely wiped out,
but we had held the line.
They held the line
adding on fathomable cost in
blood and sanity and lives.
They held the line
in men like Bob Hoffman who
met face to face with hell.
Okay.
An evil and darkness that
crushes you and laughter.
And for many people it crushes hope.
Okay.
But Bob Hoffman overcame all of that
and he came back and really from
my perspective through fitness,
he led an incredible life
and he ended up writing a book about
it and it was called how to be strong,
healthy and happy,
and that's a tall order.
That's a tall order who doesn't
want to be strong, healthy and happy
in the book eat. Some of
it's dated, much of it isn't,
but some of it's dated,
but I,
I don't want to go deep into the book,
but I do want to hit some highlights
from this book on how to be strong,
healthy and happy.
Okay.
Some things to think about.
Bob Hoffman Kiro from World War
One who'd been through hell.
I'm just going to read some quotes
from this. Physical training pays.
I always say that any exercise
is better than no exercise.
Now he talks about sleep a little bit in
those folks out there that harassed me
on Twitter,
doc parsley constantly
harassing me on Twitter.
Tell me to sleep more.
This is what does it,
what Bob Hoffman had to say about sleep.
There are different speeds of sleep,
some sleep faster than
others and can awake,
refreshed with a moderate
number of hours of sleep,
which would leave others tired and worn
fast sleeping. Is it a result of properly
operating bodily functions of Pref,
perfect functioning of all organs and
it comes to from accustoming the body to
an hour to less sleep.
Many great men of history are reported
to have slept only a fraction of the time
that the average person spends sleeping.
If we said that Thomas Edison,
the world famous inventor would
sleep up four hours a night,
but he had a cot in his laboratory
on which you would lie and think,
and his assistants have reported
he took naps during the day.
Many men who are reporting to
sleep up four hours a night,
we'll make up for it with naps during
day light hours. So there you go.
You're good to go.
That's all you need to do.
Is Sleep faster
talking to you, echo, tune in and
what do you get? Nine hours. 10 Hours?
No regular eight I think.
Nice, nice sleep faster.
Now speaking of that,
too much sleep is not a benefit.
Rather it is depressing causes,
sluggishness and a state of the Frg.
I liked that too much sleep.
Take that,
take that doc parsley out there,
but in all you know doc,
no doc parsley, he trades vaguely. Yeah,
but he's, he's, he's a doctor but he's,
he's done a lot of stuff with sleep and
studying sleep and he's always giving me
a hard time because sleep is good for you.
I'm only kidding everybody.
Sleep is definitely good for you.
I should sleep more.
I just have a hard time doing it.
There's so much to be done in the
world and you're sleeping fast and I am
sleeping with it faster than
everybody else if it didn't.
Another quote,
any young man who desires to obtain
the most from life should spend a good
portion of his time
improving himself physically.
Regardless of your age,
you should make it a rule to learn
something new each day and to do something
each day to improve yourself physically.
So he's talking about mental
and physical strength.
He talks about learning stuff, memory,
memorizing stuff, doing math in your head,
just getting smarter.
I believe we talk about that sometimes.
The best hobby of all
this physical training.
Concentrate on your activities
instead of worrying about the future.
Welcome the opportunity to face problems
or deals or battles of your life.
You can build yourself so that you
obtained pleasure from overcoming,
from defeating problems,
apparently insurmountable difficulties.
You can overcome all your difficulties in.
When you will find the
next encounter easier,
you will have greater
confidence in your own ability,
God problems. Good. Let's face him
and uh, actually I forgot to
mention this, but this book,
I remember the last war I got from
somebody on Twitter and I'm sorry.
Hey everybody on Twitter. Number one, I,
I don't know if people want
to be mentioned or not.
And also when I transfer,
what people tell me to the document that
I keep, it doesn't pull their names,
so they're just lost. But usually
people hit me up afterwards and say,
oh right, I gave you that book. So
somebody recommended the book to me.
I remember the last war and once I started
doing some research about Bob Hoffman
and I saw he had another book that
was literally called how to be strong,
healthy,
and happy.
I just ordered immediately so I could
see what he had to say about it all
and I think, yeah, some
pretty good information.
Here's another quote.
People who know nothing of the pleasures
and advantages of having super strength
and health often say
what good are muscles.
They say they have no use for them,
that they are healthy,
but they are only half alive in many
cases for they will never have felt the
indescribable sense of
power and wellbeing.
The census superiority or
capability that strong persons feel,
many use of eliminated an inferiority
complex by the growing knowledge of the
power they possessed by their physical
ability or superior already over average
persons. We might have to do an
ego check here, Bob on that one,
but actually he's going to ego
check it right here himself.
I do not mean by this that strong
men should go round bowling others by
demonstrating their
strength as an actual fact,
a stronger and more capable a man,
the less likely he is to make a show
of his strength by hurting or fighting
others.
Okay.
But strength of mind and body does
beget get confidence, determination,
perseverance and many
other admirable qualities.
Okay.
So I think he, he, he
brought it back around again.
It's for you and I were talking before
the podcast started about how some people,
if they're a little bit insecure but
they want to be a tough guy. They did.
They got to act like that.
Yeah.
And when you're within your looking at
them kind of like this guy must not be
that tough cause you've
got to act this way. Yeah.
So they actually are getting less
respect than they think they are. Yup.
But if they actually had
confidence in their situation,
if they knew that they
could handle themselves,
they wouldn't be acting like that.
Yup.
Here's another little
something to think about.
Don't worry about things
that might happen.
Work hard and do the best you can. And
if something happens, it can't be helped.
Don't give up, never cry over
spilled milk. What is done is done.
It can't be helped when it's too late.
I survived some apparently
overwhelming difficulties.
Easily enough with this point of view.
Sort of your basic cause I mean
no use crying over spilled milk.
Don't abuse down though. Cause
you know how, um, you know,
people will have the attitude but then
sometimes they'll let it overflow in the,
it'll get,
it'll make itself,
they'll allow it to be
an excuse to go prepared.
Yeah, no that's, that's not a good idea.
Yeah. Yeah. But it can do it, you know,
cause it's like a, um, there might
be a small light gray area, you know,
cause they're like,
oh,
I don't really care that much about
the outcome and what's going to happen
that's going to happen.
So it might, like I said,
overflow into the part of
their mind of preparation. Oh,
don't want to let that
happen. Yeah. So, you know,
cause the opposite is like if
you obsess over the outcome,
you might obsess over the preparation
maybe. You know what I mean? That's,
that's those kind of go hand in hand a
little bit. So if you go the opposite,
you know you can get that be like,
Eh, well, whatever's going to happen,
it's going to happen. So whatever. That's
not the excuse we're looking for. No, no,
no, no, no. That's what I say.
Be careful of that. You know.
Here we go. A few more of these. If
you want to live long and be healthy,
strong and happy,
acquire habits of activity right now.
If you are tempted to sit in an easy
chair, find something to keep you busy.
A few minutes to a half an hour
with the weights will be best.
If you find yourself going to the garage
for your car to get to the grocery
store, walk instead. I
like this one right here.
If you don't feel like
getting dressed to go out,
do it anyways instead of
wine down after a meal.
Find something to do.
Yeah,
don't pass the buck as they say
in the army. Do it yourself.
If there's an involves muscular action,
clean off the snow, cut the grass,
spade the garden.
That's a good one.
That's just a general rule.
If you don't feel like something
cause you're being lazy to do it,
don't be lazy. The thing that you
could do tomorrow, do it today,
do that thing today
[inaudible]
otherwise you get this.
If you put off until another day,
your good intentions
to normalize your body,
it won't help the road to despair and
unhappiness is paved with good intentions
lost along
the way.
I think he'd just seen him get after it
basically is what I'm getting is what
I'm getting from Bob Hoffman.
This is just an old school,
just some old schooled mileage right here.
If our country was invaded and our
young men were a lot of cream puffs,
probably cowards through never
having experienced hard work,
athletic competition or a good punch in
the nose, we would lose to the invaders,
lose our freedoms and things
worth more than life itself.
So she's basically saying it'd be
harder. Tough enough, be tougher.
I support this idea a hundred percent
do things that make you
tougher and better. Yes,
activity is life.
Stagnation is deaf in life.
There is movement.
These are all well known
truisms and exercise.
Bringing healthful
activity to every organ,
gland and cell of the body keeps the
entire body and mind radially alive and
with a feeling of pep energy and wellbeing
that makes one so buoyant and alive
that they feel like jumping and running.
Oh, he's fired up. Exercise
builds coordination, balance,
control of the muscles.
It build speech,
judgment of time and space and distance
makes the entire body more responsive to
the will and he teaches the body to
do the right thing in times of danger,
even before it is directed by the mind.
Exercise is the best.
Insurance against disease or sickness.
Exercise builds confidence for
there is no road to supreme.
Confidence has sure has the knowledge
of one's physical and mental ability.
It cultivates power of will,
gives you complete mastery of
your physical and mental self.
Promotes personal efficiency and all
desirable mental characteristics.
Okay.
Exercise improves the efficiency
of every part of the body.
Okay.
It helps you sleep sounder and faster
so that you have more time for work and
pleasure.
Yeah,
makes it possible for you to earn more.
Exercise,
makes it possible to live more.
Exercise will only take
one 10th of the time.
You now spend on foolish
expenditures of time and energy.
This is, this is funny because this
is written in like 1930 something.
Now you have time to sit around to
read for entertainment too often true
detective stories,
other true stories which do you no good
but merely tell you of the troubles of
others.
You spend a lot of time at the movies
perhaps or listening to the radio in idle
talk or gossip in
watching athletic events,
which put which others put forth
effort and receive benefit,
you know,
add the interweb into that equation and
social media and you've got no time in
the day. Yeah. It's essentially
the Internet is basically all that.
All that one on the computer. Yeah.
All that without moving all that,
just less homes, right? Yeah.
So it's sure that you can
find time for exercise,
you to obtain much of what is it
worth in life. You must find time.
Your health demands it.
Yeah.
And I'm going to wrap it up
right here with this, this one.
But probably you have done as the
majority do drifted along from day to day
promising yourself that you would start
exercising tomorrow or next week or next
month when the weather becomes cooler.
Tomorrow comes next week and next month,
cool weather and even next year comes
and goes and you do nothing about it.
After years of thinking about
exercise but not acting,
you find the firm rounded,
attractive muscles of your youth
have changed until the weekend.
Soft muscles of Middle Age,
you take on a little excess flesh and
make mental note some night when you gaze
upon yourself in the mirror that
you'll have to do something cut down on
starches or suites,
get more exercise.
But you've developed an enormous appetite
during these years and at best you
refrained from eating
sweets for a day or two.
It seems that all the things you
like are the best fat producers.
You can't give them up. You notice
you don't have endurance anymore.
You get tired after you walked a blocker
to your wind isn't as good as it used
to be. Remember last night, how you
puffed when you ran for the street car.
Remember how you met,
how it made you blow to carry you
that empty trunk up to the attic.
Your Taylor pokes you good naturedly
when he's fitting your suit and remarks
that the fattest piling on and
your waste is increasing by inches.
These are all reasons why you should
exercise. It's not too late now.
It's never too late.
As long as you are able to be around to
exercise and improve yourself physically.
Men of all ages receive quick results
from proper physical training.
It's never too late to make
corrections in your mode of living.
Some classic stuff there.
There's a little caveat there with he
says it's never too late. That's true.
That's true with Samara too late,
but
the more time that you have
spent getting into shape,
you can fall out of shape
and when you come back to it,
it'll be way easier. And I mentioned
this before, that's cool. You can,
you can keep telling yourself that I am
telling you if let's say, you're right,
you're right. You want to have a good
base. If you have a good base of being,
it's going to
be easier for you than somebody, somebody
that's never worked out before. Yes.
That's a given.
That being said,
if you take a person that's never
lifted before, never worked out before,
when they start, man, they make
all kinds of crazy gains. Right.
But keep in mind, they're still starting
at the bottom of the ladder. So yeah,
the first, you know, 10 steps in
the ladder come quickie quickly.
But that comes for everybody. Give
her to, you know, give or take.
So sure. Okay. In the small little
picture you can be like, hey,
that guy, he started on the first 10
steps of the ladder way later in life.
So look at his gains weight later in life.
But meanwhile,
you had those first
steps done 35 years ago.
You're on step 125 right now.
You are correct.
The bottom line is both groups
will benefit. Oh yeah. Big Time.
But physical activity. So the,
the point being, you know,
how any mentions this host was like,
oh,
I'll just do it tomorrow or
I'll just do it. Um, you know,
the new year's resolution or whatever,
the more time you spend not doing it,
the harder it is to get there and
stay there. Cause man, you know,
I actually have a theory on this too.
Like if you miss a workout,
you can never make it up. It's gone.
Like he gets it, he's like, it's gone.
You can never make it because you
work out the next day. But no, no.
You missed the day that you, you, that
was supposed to be a different workout.
Right.
You've got weaker,
you can't get it back that
sometimes you need a break.
I think we've got some
questions about that.
Sometimes you definitely need a
rest to your push your body so hard.
You're doing so much activity activity,
but you're not going to get that chance
to work out again and you'll want,
you're not going to chance it anytime
you waste any time in your life,
guess what? It's gone. Yeah. So
don't waste it. Don't waste it.
Don't waste it with sitting listened
to radio shows or Internet shows or
watching TV.
That's a waste.
Don't waste too with that unless the
shows are helping you. Well, yeah, yes.
If they're helping you, if
they're beneficial, if it's
Jocko podcast, man, tune in.
But if you're sitting
around, Oh yeah, reality TV,
just random social media stuff that's
not helping you get any better.
Of course you're, you're wasting it
and you're not going to get it back.
Sometimes if I miss something or
if I am lazy about something that,
that that pisses me off and at the
time I'll say, oh well, you know, I'll,
I'll rationalize some excuses
around it and then later I'll say,
what is your problem? Why did you do
that? And then it's punishment time.
Let's go get the squat rack.
And you tell him to pay for that.
I think, I'm going to put this real
bluntly almost to the point of ignorance,
but I think you value rest
way less than a normal person.
I think I,
I'm not going to argue with you or it
could be that you value the work part of
it so much that your rest
is quantity wise less,
but quality wise might be more.
And also like for instance,
I don't get the opportunity,
I mean when I travel, like for Princeton,
when I travel, I barely leave recently,
I have not had time to do
Jujitsu and I'm traveling,
so when I'm back here I got
to just get it in, you know?
And if I miss it when I'm in San Diego,
I'm not happy.
I'm angry at myself and I
won't even let it happen.
I'm just not going to let it happen.
Even yesterday I was all tired
and beat up and I was like, okay,
well go train all tired
and beat up because you're
going to miss some days this
week.
So you've got to just go get it on work
on being weak and lame and getting your,
getting your game on.
And I went and rolled with a bunch
of people and do what I normally do.
And you know what, by the time
you're in the middle of a rolling,
it doesn't matter anymore. You're just
dealing with a situation. Yeah, man,
if you can get to that point where you
know how you did this kind of a weird one
where it's really good, really,
really good exercise, but it's really,
really fun to do. Yeah. So it's
like a win win you don't like.
So weightlifting I think is like that,
but it's not like that for everybody
where it's like it's fun to actually do,
even though sometimes you got to
kind of build up the, you know,
kind of the energy or whatever to, you
know, motivation, whatever to do it.
It's still pretty fun.
But for most people I would,
I would argue most people exercises like
work, it's like a chore, the benefit.
And I think the more you do it and
the better you get at it. Yeah.
Either more fun. It is,
the more you enjoy it.
For me it's a mental break. You know,
it's a mental break from everything else.
You know what I'm gonna do?
I'm going to go pick up this,
this piece of metal off the ground.
Lunchtime bunch of times. Yeah. And,
and the point there is,
if you can get to that state
where actually doing the
exercise separate from the
results actually doing
it is, is fun. You can,
you can recognize the pleasure in it.
Um,
that's when you can be on a program.
You know how,
like I just got back from quiet
little like a vacation, but I still,
I still rolled, I still,
uh, did, you know,
lifted weights and exercise
great. Train with went so, um,
before, and I think most people,
it's when it's vacation time,
they're off the program.
And I'm not even saying I'm
in specifically on a program,
but it's just too hard on the life
program on the deal men. So if you,
if you're into it, you know, like, oh,
I look forward to going
and training at a new spot.
This is a lot of fun to be had there.
There's a lot of fun to be,
I'm going to trade the,
the normal spot.
But if you're in that mindset where you
liked the exercise that you're doing,
but you'll do it, you go on
vacation, you'll do it then. Yeah.
Looking forward to it.
Yeah. There's no doubt.
So you don't fall off having fun
when you train as is and enjoying it.
I guess having fun cause it's not like
when I'm in the middle of the set of
clean and jerks, I'm having fun. But
that's kind of what it mean though.
Where, um, I remember when I
used to play football we'd,
we'd test in Olympic lifting. So like
power clean was one and snatch was one.
And I remember training for those things.
If you get kind of good at the technique,
right? Comes Fun with your friends,
they're yelling and stuff like that.
So it's fun.
I guess I was thinking more of like a
met cons when you're all wanting a good
example,
be just being frank with you.
I'm not always having fun during those.
Sometimes I want to not do it. Yeah.
And I still do it, but I don't
want to, it's just not fun.
I would say more times than not,
especially any kind of met constitution
that's going to be the case.
So my overall point is if you can get to
that point where at the very least you
can appreciate this. That's
happening right now. I like,
I find you some pleasure in here.
And furthermore,
I will tell you this,
if you get to know the feeling of how you
feel when you complete a hard workout,
you go, you know what?
It's going to be worth it.
Because when I get done with this,
I'm going to feel like x, right?
I'm going to feel good. And so
that for me, that's why I'm,
I think that's kind of why I'm doing
hard workouts because I'm doing hard
workouts because I know that at the
end of it I'm going to be like, yeah,
I feel I'm going to feel good.
Yeah,
I'm going to feel fired up
for the rest of the day.
I'm going to feel like I did something.
Well.
I'm going to feel like
a quality human being.
Like I didn't waste a little section
section of my life full feel good.
Yeah.
So when you know what that,
it's the same thing with waking up in
the morning when you sleep in that that
feels good at the moment. But then
when you wake up you're like, oh man,
I just wasted part of my life. Whereas
when you get up, even though it's hard,
when you know how good it feels to be
done with your workout that early in the
morning and be like, yeah, I'm ready.
You bring it, bring on the tasks.
And it's strange thing about
workout is the workout pays you,
pays you back for your work afterwards.
It's basically a,
you know,
you work out in the workout isn't
what makes your muscles big.
It's the response to the workout.
So when you work out,
it's Kinda like you did your part and
now your body is going to pay you back
with your gains, you know? True. So you're
like, Hey, I'm done with the workout.
I can go do some other stuff. Meanwhile I
got that check coming, that gains check.
That's a good daily. So
yeah, that's awesome.
And now I think it's about time
we go to the interwebs. Sure.
But first you can actually support
the podcast through the interwebs.
Echo. We do it well. Let the troopers, no,
one of the ways,
um,
which may sound repetitive but
necessarily so in my opinion,
it.com/jocko
cause some people they want to improve
their improvement with supplements and we
recommend all we, I recommend supplements
that work. I'm assuming you do too.
I actually do. Yeah, there you go.
So you get them from Onnit. Yup.
On att.com/jocko shroom tech.
These are the ones I take or have taken.
Shroom tech,
Alpha Brain Krill
oil from me. Yeah. We're addicts.
Their audit out of Krill oil
right now as a tailwind. Yeah.
There'll be plenty of Krill.
Just keep,
keep your finger on the pulse of the
Krill oil situation and then the um,
or your bar boom. That one's good. That's
an it. Is that a supplement, do you think?
Would you call this food that's tasty?
Yeah.
On it.com/jocko get 10%
off all supplements.
It's dope.
Also if you like the shirts that we make,
go to [inaudible] dot com and get
one or more of that of those. Um,
and then, uh, yeah, that's a
good way to support I think.
And then
before you do your Amazon shop shopping,
clickthrough Jocko,
podcast.com, there's like, there's
a little link on there. Um,
and then Jocko stories while this
Amazon Linkedin, click there first,
then do the shopping. Um, also on the
Jocko podcast website, we have all,
I put all the books that you cover on
all these podcasts so you can see what
they're about. Click on it if you
want to get one of those books
and then,
okay.
audible.com audible is just the
way to listen to audio books.
So what they're doing is they're
giving you 30 days free 30.
Um, if you go to audible.com/jocko so
you get 30 days free and then you get to
download a free book.
But once you, did they download?
Do you think, would you recommend,
I think my recommendation would clearly
be a little book by Jocko Willink and
Leif Babin called extreme ownership.
We actually read the audio book too.
So if you like the Jocko podcast,
you're probably going to like here
in the extreme ownership read bios.
It's about eight hours long.
So it's like getting four podcasts,
maybe even five podcasts.
But yeah, you know,
we've gotten some really because of the
support people of showing the podcast
and it's becoming more popular.
We been getting hammered by a bunch of
people that want to sponsor us and we
don't want a bunch of sponsors.
In fact, we don't want any.
The only thing we want is if
there's things that can help people,
help people get better, well
then that's what we want. So on,
it gives you the supplements that you
need, some of the gear that you need.
And then on top of that
you've got all the bowl,
which is a way to listen to books while
you can't have the ability to read.
So if you're driving,
if you're doing yard work,
if you're doing some something that
requires your hands and your eyes,
you can just listen to a
book on audible.com/jocko
and so that's a another way
to also then thereby support the podcast.
30 days free book.
Do it get smarter.
I recommend the extreme ownership as well.
It's interesting that you guys read it
cause that's not always the case, right?
Sometimes it's, it's like a
professional reader or whatever. But um,
like if you know what leafs voice
sounds like, sounds like Batman.
He does have bad anyway.
There it is. Yes, indeed.
So yeah, there you go. Let's get to
the question of questions. I'm down.
All right.
First Question Jocko,
do you ever feel burnt out from going
full tilt several days or several weeks in
a row? And if so, what do you do?
Never. No, of course. Um,
you know,
burning the candle at both ends.
Eventually it's gonna catch up with you.
And for me,
it's can come in the form of too
much travel, too much exercise.
Sometimes I'll just be pressed at work,
working with a bunch
of different companies.
Sometimes I'm writing and I'm trying
to get a bunch of writing done.
Sometimes I'm training so much
Jujitsu it's going crazy. So anyways,
or a lot of times it's the combination
of all these things going on at once
cause I'm trying to get a bunch done
in a short amount of time and I end up
whatever coming off the common
off the track a little bit,
coming off the rails a little bit and so
what do I do on those kind of days when
I'm starting to feel like
that? Well, number one,
I like to force myself to do it anyways.
That is a reality.
So if even if I'm, if I don't feel like
working out, I'll be like, you know what,
just go do a quick workout and easy and
easy or workout or I don't want to train
Jujitsu.
We were talking about this earlier.
Don't really feel like training
going to go train anyways.
Then maybe there's some form of
work that I'm supposed to do.
I'm just going to go
and do the work anyways.
Now if if the next day I still
feel like I need a break,
that's sort of my red flag
to say, all right, you know
what? You need a break. Uh,
you need to take some time, time, relax.
Um,
do some kind of active rest.
I don't really like just
kind of sitting around.
I'll do something kind of active
and probably eat some steaks,
plural, trying to eat something really
good, trying to eat some just, you know,
I might,
I might eat something really
good like steaks and maybe sleep,
take an extra nap,
try and feel better,
do some kind of stretching to try and
feel better just to recover, just recover.
So yes, I'm not super human like anybody
else. Sometimes it get broken down,
beaten up and I need some downtime and
that's what I do. I try and rest, relax
and eat some good food.
Yeah,
that's a good one that I started to
incorporate how you were seeing. Um,
if I don't feel like it or if I feel like
I'm starting to get burnt out, you'll,
you'll, it's like that one last
thing. Let me just do it anyway.
Then I'll see if I do it.
You know,
because sometimes like how you say you
avoid the situation where you just not in
the mood. If you're in some
days you just not in the mood,
but it doesn't mean you're burnt out,
you're just not in the
mood for whatever reason.
So that's a good way to kind of weed
those days out. And um, and yeah,
if you're still burnt out the next
day or even the next day after that,
then it's like, okay,
you gotta arrest. Um,
I started doing that and
you'd be surprised what it,
how many times you really not burnt out.
You're just not in the mood that's a B
do, you might not agree with
this, but if you are like,
whether it be burnt out or just tired
of, uh, you know, you're, you're just,
you're just tired of the grind or whatever
and you need a break or vacation or
whatever.
What I saw,
what I sometimes do is
don't do like filming for example,
where there would be times where I would
spend like months just filming every
week fill.
I didn't feel like no break and what I
do is don't do any of it and don't think
about it,
don't just don't do it at all.
And then slowly and I,
in my experience,
I was surprised how quick
it came back where you,
you kind of want to get back to it,
but then I go like like a week or
still not doing it. It's like Jujitsu.
If you're like, Oh man, I'm tired
to training every day or whatever,
you had to turn them in or
whatever and you're like, man,
I got to take a break after
about probably like three days.
If you're a competitor three
days where you're like, man,
I want to get back on the mats.
So what you do is you push that even more.
So it's like you're, you're pushing
yourself to be burnt out on the recovery.
So the only,
the only medicine for that burnt out
of recovery is to get back into it.
But that hunger of getting back into it
is even more than it normally would be.
Normal break. That makes sense. I guess.
And I just want to call us in both out
right now for being total cream puffs,
I think is what Bob often said.
Here we are talking about how we get
burnt out on working out training,
filming. It's like Bob,
Bob Hoffman was, you know,
living in the seeds of
mustard gas floating around
and maybe we should just say
don't get burnout. Just
work harder. Sorry.
You maybe thought a real bad they're
filming. No, I mean I was like, oh,
I was typing on a computer on
real burnt out. Shut up Jocko.
I've got a better idea.
Why don't you just be fired up that you
have the opportunity to create something?
How's that sound?
Oh,
you got the opportunity to go train
Jujitsu to go get better physically. Oh,
I think I'm going to go ahead and do that.
I'm not going to sit there and say
burnout out on training. No, no, no.
Be burnout if Bob Hoffman is not burned
out on the front lines of World War One.
I don't think we have an excuse to be
burnout on the pleasurable things we get
to do in life, but suck it up and
just drive on. I'm changing my answer.
There you go.
Next question Jocko.
Hi Guys. How about judo as a
martial art compared to Jujitsu?
Judo is a great martial art and Jujitsu
is actually rooted in judo and I guess
originally judo was rooted in Jujitsu
and there are some connections or I mean
my eda from Japan.
He taught judo to Carlos Gracie in Brazil
which was then learned by alien Gracie
who then morphed it into what we consider
now to be Brazilian or Gracie Jujitsu.
But you can see clearly if you look
at judo that Jujitsu exists inside.
I mean Brazilian Jiu Jitsu exist inside
of judo. There's no doubt about it,
but there are some things about judo
that have morphed it into a different
direction. Number one, in judo,
if you throw somebody and anything
touches the ground before their feet,
you went automatically.
You can also pin people in judo.
If you hold them down for,
I think it's 20 seconds,
then the match is over
and you win both of those.
So what that does is now you can imagine
if you get thrown, okay, you win.
If you're on the ground with your
back down for 20 seconds, you win.
So what does that do? It eliminates a
part of fighting that is very important.
And in there are really
two pieces of judo.
One of them is called Randori,
which is basically rolling and the other
one is Newaza, which is ground work.
And those two are directly
correlated or part of Jujitsu.
But jujitsu bottom line in both these,
if you don't know
anything about these two,
Jujitsu allows the fight to go
on even after you get thrown.
And it allows the fight. You can't,
there's no pinning in Jujitsu.
You are allowed to fight and continue
to fight until the match is over.
And you can recover from being pinned
just like you can recover from being
frozen. And it doesn't
really matter. I mean,
today we were training today and we got
some good judo players. Keeling was,
you know, judo keeling.
Yeah. And he, he tossed,
he tossed Andy Big Andy and I mean cause
he's better at judo and he tossed him
and it was legit.
Then Andy ended up getting out of that
position and getting in a better position.
Right. And so the fight wasn't over
just cause he got right. And so that's,
that's one of the big benefits of Jujitsu
is that you will generally learned
better ground game
and but judo you will definitely
have better takedowns.
I mean a judo player is going to have
better take downs that a Jujitsu player
and I'll tell you if we're just
going to start ranking things,
you've got to throw wrestling out there
because wrestling has possibly better
take downs. The judo, I mean
with the geese. Sure. Judo
has a, it has an advantage.
But if you don't know this,
in 2010 they actually banned the double
leg take down from judo competitions in
the whole world. Right? Why?
Because wrestlers came in and started
double leg in people. Boom, boom.
Just hitting double legs.
So yes,
I would say judo is an
awesome martial art.
It really in some ways could be considered
the precursor to Brazilian Jujitsu,
even though judo itself is,
comes from actual Japanese Jujitsu.
But I would say if you're going to,
if you've got the opportunity to learn in
judo, yeah, learn it, learn especially,
you know,
you'll learn the takedowns and those
are great things to have in real life.
They're great things to have in,
in self defense situations.
To be able to take someone down
with judo throws is awesome.
In jujitsu competitions, if you're a
judo player in Jujitsu competitions,
you're going to,
you're going to get the take down
with when it's a key competence,
unless you're going against
a really good wrestler.
So good thing to augment Jujitsu with.
But I would say you would want
to make Jujitsu your main focus.
I agree that,
yeah.
So a lot of times when you learn, did you
to some, a lot of, especially nowadays,
a lot of guys avoid that.
The takedown LMS.
So they know ground game is just vast,
but the takedown elements.
So you'll get a lot of
people pulling garden,
which just means pulling a guy down
on top of you. That's what filling,
which is a crazy thing to do in
a real fight. Yeah. But, but man,
if you're good for sure you can totally
do that. That's what's crazy about it.
No,
even if you're really good at it,
you don't want to be pulling
people on top of you.
I did compare it to it and being able to
take them down compared to being on the
side of no brainer. Yeah. Not
even close. So what I like about,
I mean wrestling I think is more,
I mean arguably more,
more dynamic of,
of a thing because it's all
these different situations
even on top of just the
takedown part. But man, judo,
I feel like it takes a little less
energy and it can kind of keep you in.
Positionally can keep you in safe areas
when you're standing up. Cause you know,
like these weird positions where you're
on balance in that guys off balance or
you, you're controlling the guys
wait when you're standing up. And um,
so I learned like a signal.
I took judo when I was young for just
for a little bit and then I never would
have guessed that for a little bit anyway.
And then, but as an adult I
learned a little bit of judo,
um, from, from Terry. So could you see
of the judo background? Um, and man,
he was showing me stuff. He was
like, Hey, wrestlers will do this.
And he'd kind of show or they grab
your head, neck and, and he's like,
and here's what you do as a judo guy guy.
And he,
it's an elaborate thing he
taught me, but it's like, Dang,
these are real useful things for Jujitsu.
Even aside from the take down part of it
and then going to the take down part of
it.
If you know the takedowns solid,
even if you don't like three or four
really good ones and you're really good at
them, that'll change your whole approach
and your whole outlook on Jujitsu. So,
okay, here's an example. Let's
say you go into, I dunno,
you know party here everyday thing where
you could find yourself in a situation
where you got to,
you got to get in a fight or defend
yourself or your friend or whatever.
If you know take downs,
especially take downs where you don't
have to like risk like doing the double
leg in a real situation. That's kind of
an all or nothing situation. You know,
you can't just,
it's not like this gradual escalating
of force with a double leg take down.
With judo it's different,
much more subtle with your takedowns
with varying levels of force,
you know with the, with the
judo situation. So if, and
if you're good at that, men,
when you get into these situations,
it's like no factor.
You not worried about it at all
compared to like you don't know,
take putting your Jujitsu
is sick. You're like, Nah,
I got to get this thing to the ground and
it's like that's going to be a pain in
the ass once we get there,
I'm fine.
But just that one little crossover
from standing or no fight to fight.
It's like they kind of can
provide some anxiety for you.
But if you know that
doodle, whatever. Yep.
The, I guess the overall point is
learned that judo very useful not right.
And that's not to mention when the other
guy knows it, you know what to do to.
Yeah, because otherwise I'm just getting
tossed keeling, toss me the other guy.
Oh yeah.
And sometimes it can be funny and fun
cause you know they can toss to you and
you landed on your back and stuff like
that with Manson, you land on your head.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
There is some validity to the a pawn in
that if you were in a street fight and
you got thrown and land and the
person puts you down in a bad way,
I mean you're still, it's, it's like,
it's not like you're going to
get knocked out 100% of the time.
Probably not even 50% of the time,
but there is a,
there is a chance that getting thrown it
palm style in a street fight could be,
I mean,
you go go pull up some judo videos of
people getting tossed it bone style.
Even in the, in the high levels. Some of
those guys, if they landed on the street,
they would be injured not all the time.
And you do learn to,
you learn to fall in judo, you learn
how to break your fall. But yeah,
some of those would be devastating
if they happen to you in the street.
So that's why iPhone does
have some validity to it,
that if you tossed someone super hard
and they landed on their back or on their
head on the street on concrete, they
would be severe. They would be that.
It could be a fight ender, but,
but it's not going to be a fighter.
That's the problem.
It's not going to be a fight ender.
It's possible that it is a just like,
uh,
a left hook is possibly a fight ender,
but it's not guaranteed Dan to fight.
I'll tell you a guaranteed fight, ender
rear naked choke. Willing to fight. Yeah.
And if I'll tell you in knowing some judo
and especially knowing some judo moves
that I feel like I'm pretty solid at.
If you do it against the guy who doesn't
really know that much judo. Oh yeah.
It's your choice whether you want
to put them on his head or his back.
It's your choice.
So if,
if that's the other guys' choice that
you're fighting with or competing against
or whatever, then that's
his choice, not yours.
So that's the reason to at least know.
Yeah, for sure. You should
know for sure. I learned judo,
learn wrestling,
learn Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is the most complicated. Learn
it first. Spend the most time on it.
Learning to strike to more Thai boxing,
saying this for the millions of times.
Although I actually do sometimes leave
judo out, not intentionally, but just,
I just do.
Yeah.
I personally liked wrestling.
I like it personally.
I like it better than wrestling because
when I was started to learn wrestling
with them, Greg, Greg, train
on you. Come and get you.
Why tell him this too. But this,
I'm not saying I dislike wrestling,
I'm just saying I like judo
better because like I said,
when you shoot a double or a single or
something and he stuffs it in a bet,
a worse situation than if
you go for, you know, some,
you know saying doggy or something and
you don't get, well he's on your back.
But you know what I mean
though, it failed. Judo throw,
you have way less of a
price to pay typically.
Do you usually have less of a price to
pay on a judo throw than you do in a
wrestling, takedown understanding verse?
It depends, but yes, generally speaking,
in my experience,
that's why
I'll,
I'll give that to you with like a,
like a small percentage of
agreement that not a full, yeah,
I mean it's not that black and white
for sure. That's Greco guys, Greco,
Roman Russell. Now they're not
shooting on you anymore and believe me,
you're getting tossed. You know,
you train with a good Greco guy.
They're not grabbing your legs at all.
They're not even shooting,
but they are throwing you right. And
they don't have to grab the Gita do it.
So Greco Greco Greco was awesome.
Yeah, I agree. Um, and
then also the judo thing,
it tends to, in my experience, um,
take less out of you.
You know, it's, it's a less,
it's somewhere in between Jujitsu
and wrestling is the exertion. Yeah.
Jeffery phone, black and
white. A lot of generalities.
Please don't go crazy because of
some generalities that echo made
quick. Wait, are we good there?
Do you have any more to add?
I have nothing further to add. Alright.
Keep training everything you can. Yeah,
I liked the judo.
Thumbs
up for the Judah though, for
sure. Question number three.
What's your recommendation for
an employee that is late to work?
Who usually is late but they're
usually a good performer.
So being late is unacceptable.
And I,
I tell us when I've right
pork with a company and they
start talking about, well,
you know,
this guy is late for a meeting sometimes.
I always tell him that I was in the
military for 20 years and I was literally
never late. I was literally
never late one time. Yeah.
We'll think about that 20 years.
Never late, never late, never late.
Any time for anything we would,
you know,
we would show up at work in the morning
so early that even if the worst case
scenario, my, I got t
boned on the way to work,
I would still be able to get insurance,
get everything covered,
get a cab and still show
up and be an hour early.
So you should be,
you're right in the fact that being on
time is definitely very, very important.
So people shouldn't be late.
So now with this individual got someone
that's showing up late for work,
you got it.
Like any other leadership challenge,
what I would attack is making
sure they understand why.
Why is it important?
Some people never make the connection
as to why being on time is important.
So you got to explain to
them why it's important.
You got to explain to them that's
basic respect for other people's time.
That it's basic operational readiness
is to follow a timeline that it's about
being prepared,
that it's about showing your reliability
and your professionalism to two other
people that you're working with
inside and outside of your company.
Yeah.
And even Sun Su
sewn too. And I, I didn't
say this during the,
during the podcast that
we did about Sun Su,
and I can't believe I didn't say it
because I always believe in luck.
Waking up early and being early and Sun
Tzu said that he who is waiting on the
battlefield is gonna win and who he was
rushing late to the battlefield is gonna
lose. Well, that's the
way your life is too.
And if you're rushing and you things are
disorganized and you're running late,
it's horrible.
But if you wake up early and you show
up early and you're ready and you're
prepared and you're waiting on the
battlefield, you're going to win.
That's all there is to it.
So those are the important things that
you have to explain to your employee that
they,
so that they understand why being late
is an unacceptable and why being on time
is the standard that needs to
be maintained. Some people,
it's a horrible habit that some
people have of being, wait,
it's a horrible habit. Yeah. You
don't want to get into it. It just,
just unreliability. Yeah. Um, I,
it was one of those people,
I used to work in the nightclub in here,
San Diego downtown for awhile too,
from like seven years.
And unlike you, I feel like, I
feel like, I don't know, I don't,
I didn't engage it or another count them,
but it feels like I was late at the
very least one minute late, you know,
you have a shift, right. And
it starts at whatever time,
either one minute late or 10 minutes late,
I feel like I was more late,
more times than I was on
time. I feel like. Right.
So my dad was always late.
I come from a long line of late guys,
so to speak, but nonetheless. Um,
but I was this guy, I was the guy who
was a good performer. Right? I felt like,
I mean, according to my bosses and
stuff, and I would, you know, I do well,
other than the time thing,
I was pretty reliable,
very reliable in the nightclub industry.
So, and I'd always justify it like,
man,
all this time I would take to be prepared
to get there and find parking and all
this stuff. I could be doing
something else in my life or whatever.
Not necessarily useful stuff,
but just something else.
Why do I have to work while
I'm not working? You know,
like preparing for work.
I know that was kind of my attitude.
As long as I have good output,
as long as my job is being done,
it's fine. So when I stopped the,
you know, when I was done
with the nightclub industry,
jade, my brother would, um,
he explained it to me where in the,
the,
the thing that I read that really kind
of hit me was being late is a blatant
disregard and a blatant
display of disrespect to the
person or people who were
waiting for you, no doubt
about it. Their time,
which is time is like when
you really think about,
it's the most valuable thing you have.
So even if you're talking about one
minute or he's talking about one hour,
you are wasting that person's time. If
you have a meeting or something, right?
You show up five minutes late, people
were waiting for you to start the meeting.
That's five minutes gone where, you know,
we still have to go over that material,
so we're going to spend an extra five
minutes just because you're relate,
because you failed to prepare.
Everyone else was there on time and
you're the one doing it, you know. So,
and then also I learned through a,
I want to say it was a book I read,
I forget where, but um,
where one of the two major,
the main things that ensure your success
or we'll get in the way of your success
is reliability, being reliable. So, and,
and w one day I went to the store,
right?
And my wife sends me in the
shopping sprees. She says,
get this kind of tomatoes,
canned tomatoes.
But it was like at this specific kind of,
you ever tried to go chat for
canned tomatoes, Broccoli?
There's like this one and this
one, this one. And I'm like,
I'm just going to either just grab one,
anyone cause I can't find this one
or I'm not going to get him at all.
I'm just going to go home and be like,
you get to tomatoes if you want.
I don't even want whatever it
is you're making with shit. So
I have a bat, I'm getting
frustrated on the insight like, oh,
like low down the line of frustrating
things that I've told myself all the way
to the point of this
isn't my job to do this.
It is my job by the way, but this
isn't my job. I don't want to meet.
It was why should I even,
why am I even shopping right now?
I'm making a point and in my opinion is a
very important point. So if I do
that, if I'm like, you know what?
Screw it,
I'm not getting the tomatoes or I'm just
going to go ahead and settle for the
wrong one.
I've demonstrated and basically
proclaim that I am unreliable.
So why would anyone come to me
for anything who's disabled?
I'm going to be reliable
about it. And sure, you might
be reliable on some things,
but you've demonstrated that you can
and will be unreliable under certain
circumstances and those circumstances
are dictated by by you. So who knows?
Really. You're not gonna
get hired. No, you're not.
You might not even be somebody's
friend when you think about it. Yeah.
Or husbands or whatever,
you know,
it shows lack of being on time shows a
total disrespect for other people's time
and it shows a lack of
reliability on your part.
So these are the kinds of things you
got to explain to your subordinates or
explain to this person that's
being constantly late so
that they understand why
you're telling them that and then you
they can then they can improve and then
you can, you know, if the
person's a good performer,
generally that means
that her type of person,
I care about how they're
perceived and doing a good job.
So let's get them to understand how
being late effects everybody else and
affects their own reputation as,
as a performer.
Yeah. So it'll mean something to them.
Plus you'll be at come through guy.
Everyone likes to come through.
Guy Guy who comes through.
I'm sure they liked you
for coming in on time.
Every single day for 20
years they did mix question.
Okay.
You stated in prior podcasts that you are
grateful for an understanding wife who
allowed you to treat your seal
career as a number one priority.
Do you believe that marriage and children
should bring about a reprioritization
of your life? Given that marriage and
Al brings another person on your life,
a partner,
but also someone who relies on you and
especially children who heavily rely on
you. How did you reconcile, still treating
the seals as a number one priority,
both the wife and children you brought,
willing to willingly into your life?
Was there a point that despite having
an understanding of life that you should
have made the decision to end the seal
career early because of people you have a
newfound responsibility for debatably
a responsibility greater than the
responsibility for your career.
So this one, this is something that
can be for people to understand,
but yes,
the seal teams was my number
one priority over my family,
over my wife, over my
kids, over my own life,
over everything.
And just Fyi,
I literally told my wife that before we
got married multiple times on the way to
the chapel or to the San Diego courthouse
to get married on the way there on the
bridge, driving from corn auto
to San Diego. I said, hey listen,
I just want to give you one last chance.
Being a seal is not just what I do.
It's who I am and you are not going to
change me so don't think that I'm going
to change. And she was like,
oh, I know, I know what you are.
You still want to do
this? Yes, let's go do it.
And what was good was to her credit,
she didn't try and challenge that.
She didn't try and fight that.
She gave that to me.
She understood it and it's probably one
of the reasons why we stayed married for
so long and a lot, I mean to
seal teams, if you don't know,
this has about a 90% divorce rate.
It's an astronomical divorce rate.
And the reason a lot of it is because
the guys are so dedicated to the seal
teams that everything else starts
taking a a second, a backseat.
Now I think that my wife actually saw
that I was loyal and I was dedicated to
the seal teams and therefore she saw
that as something that was positive and
something that would transfer
over to other parts of my life,
including my family.
Now to answer more on this guy's question,
I want to think about this being a seal.
The best thing I could do for my
family was be dedicated to my job.
It was the best thing I could do
for the others tools I worked with.
It was the best thing I
could do for myself and for
my family was to be the best
seal possible. Why? Because
we're going into combat.
Okay.
And if I want to come home alive to my
family and I want my brothers to come
home alive to their families,
the best thing we could possibly do for
our families is to be totally dedicated
to the job so that we're ready,
we're prepared,
and we can bring each other back.
So I, that's the way it is.
And I would stand by that to this day.
And it actually does transfer in many
cases to normal civilian careers because
being
hardworking and being dedicated,
your job generally is going to translate
to being more successful in your job
and if you're more successful in your job,
you have more financial stability,
right? If you have more financial, I mean,
how many fights in families take
place because of finances? I mean,
I think that's probably the leading cause
of problems and families is there is a,
there's financial strain and so I think
that it does translate somewhat to
people in their normal careers,
even if they're not seals,
if they're not preparing for war,
that they're trying to do a good job,
they're being dedicated to their jobs
so that they can perform better and have
more stability in their lives. And
by the way, when you work harder,
you get rewarded more.
It also eventually translates into
more freedom because you move into a
leadership position.
Maybe you go into a situation where
you're no longer working for somebody
directly and there are over
you and they're demanding.
Now all of a sudden you get a
little more freedom. You can,
you can dictate what happens in your
life more. So that's important as well.
And also into on top of all that,
guess what? The way you act
and the way you carry yourself,
you are actually teaching your
family and your children something.
Okay?
Now, if you're a warrior,
if you're a military guy,
if you're then you or your children,
guess what?
Warriors have been going away to war for
thousands and thousands and thousands
of years and people have
been just fine from that.
The men have been raised by their moms
because their dad was gone away to war.
That's the way it is.
So I think that that's okay.
It doesn't mean that the warrior
doesn't love his family. He does,
but he's got a job to do and he's
going to go do it. And also if again,
if you apply that to a
normal civilian situation,
if your children see that you are
dedicated, that you are hardworking,
that you are a loyal,
that's a positive example that
you're setting for your kids.
Now,
of course,
okay.
The the shouldn't be thinking and I
never came home to my kids and said,
hey look, you're number two on the list
of priorities around here right now.
I might've said, listen,
I've got a job to do.
I've got guys that are depending on me,
we're going to combat
bad things can happen.
I need to be ready and I need to be ready
for my guys and I need to be ready for
you.
And so I don't think you need to
throw it in people's face and say, no,
you're the number two priority,
but your family should understand
that you're working hard for them.
You're building their future,
you're building it, you're,
you're building a legacy for your family.
That's what you're doing when
you're working hard at any job.
So I think that's a good,
I think that's a good example to set.
Okay.
And I think that there's nothing wrong
with that example now where people can go
too far, which of course they can,
they can do it in the military,
they can do it in their civilian career
where the job becomes not just the short
term, um, priority.
Because I will say this,
my longterm priority was my family,
right?
That was the long term priority.
I mean I had these, the, you know,
my wife and kids I'm going to raise them
are going to put that they're going to
be with me forever. That's the,
that's what I'm doing with my life.
So the long term priority is definitely
the family, but the short term priority,
and by short term, when I'm talking to
years, right? Two years, five years,
three years, that's a long, that's a short
term priority compared to your family,
which is going to be
with you until you die.
And so I think you need to keep that
in mind and make sure that you're not
sacrificing things long term.
You know the words,
if you're going to destroy your
marriage because you're working so hard,
you got problems.
If you're going to destroy your marriage
because you're dedicated to much to
your job,
that's not,
that's not supporting the longterm
strategy of taking care of your family.
So that's sort of where I
come out on that. And again,
tons of credit to my, to my wife
and my kids who were, you know,
I was gone all the time and they
dealt with it. And guess what,
I'm gone a lot too now I'm
traveling all the time. And again,
they all know that, hey, I'd love
to be staying home with them,
but I've got to take care of the family.
I've got to support the family,
I've got to maintain
my situation so that I can take care of
them if something bad were to happen.
Yeah.
And I think they understand that.
Yeah. And that's, I think that's
a big component where you know,
your wife and your kids, they do
understand. And I'm assuming, I mean,
given what I know about you guys is that,
that you're,
you're pretty clear through
what you say and what you do.
That you are supporting them and
they are a part of your life.
You don't cause some people,
let's say, I don't know,
this is a hypothetical situation, but
let's say a cop, right? Or detective,
he's really into his job. He's frustrated
with the job and this goes for any job.
The comes home, he's frustrated because
whatever work stuff he comes home,
but he's not dedicated to his
relationship or his family that much.
So he allows the frustrations of work to
carry over, carry over. He takes it out
on his wife because she said, you know,
do the dishes,
you forgot whatever.
She then he's even more mad
because he's frustrated with work.
Like that kind of thing where, you know,
he kind of in the back of his mind,
he regards his family as
something that should, I dunno,
serve him while he does his,
you know, real lot in life,
which is be an amazing detective,
you know.
So I think a lot of times there's that.
And then on top of it,
the family wife or
the wife,
um,
has these expectations that are not clear,
not,
not correct,
but it that way you know,
where you know you should be
home at a certain time. You know,
you shouldn't be working late. You know,
where your family, that's the worst.
It's like I'm not coming home like, oh,
I'm done with work and the seal teams,
I'm done with work,
but I'm going to the bar with the guys
and I'll be home at midnight or one
o'clock in the morning or two o'clock
in the morning. And guess what,
my wife actually understood that.
She actually understood that, hey,
these guys are a team, these guys
are a family of their own right.
And I got to let him go and develop and
hang out with his friends because he's
got to know these guys better than anybody
in the world. Yeah, see and that's,
that's, that's a hard thing for
a, for some people to handle.
And now when you've got to be
careful with navy seals, to me, yeah,
that's absolutely true and legitimate.
But some guys might use that as like an
excuse just to not have to come home and
wash dishes, you know, of
course then they're, then
they're wrong. Right, right. So,
you know, kind of be careful with Allen,
like, um, you know, I dunno a sales guy,
he closes the deal and guys
want to celebrate, you know,
meanwhile it's done. I know mother's
Day or something, I don't know,
something or something to eat or
Thursday can eat it, you know? Um,
and you know,
I don't think it's unreasonable for
wives to have certain expectations,
especially if you don't
address them. Like, you know,
you don't communicate or whatever. Like
you have expectations, you have to,
you have an expectation for your
husband to come home after work you do.
So if he just doesn't show up all of a
sudden, yeah. You know, I mean you're,
I'm assuming you're going to tell your
wife, Hey, I'm not gonna. This is why.
Just like, are you saying you're
going to explain everything? But some,
they're like, I'm the man, I don't have
to come home right now if I don't want to.
Which is kind of true. But you're
in a relationship, you're in a team,
especially good in.
And really,
I would say one thing that's awesome about
my wife is I would say, Oh yeah, sorry,
I didn't come home.
I was going out with the boys and she
was independent enough and secure enough
and confident enough that she was
like, oh, okay, whatever. Hey,
I'm going to go on to do
this. Most of the time, yeah,
there was some times flowers were
bought, things were, things were rebuilt.
Uh, because you know, it's,
uh, it's life, right? Yeah.
And no one's going to be like 100%
focused on that. Um, you know,
that situation or the, the, the, um, you
know, you go, how you say you, you said,
I'm a navy seal, don't, you know,
don't change me or whatever. She,
that's not going to be on the front of
her mind hundred percent of the time she
has. She's a person, you know, and
she loves, they can change you.
Yeah. And even if they
know, ultimately they can't,
they still for a day they might, you
know, and it can go back, you know,
back and forth. So yeah, it's not
going to go perfect, but as long,
just like how you were
saying you that early
and she is a strong enough person to be
like understand that and understand the
value of that throughout the
whole process, then you know,
then you're going to have
success with that kind of thing.
But it depends on how good you
communicate it and how willing the Ger,
your wife or husband or
whatever the situation is. Um,
it depends on how good they can receive
it and go through it because some people
are needy, man. Yeah.
And you know, though,
a lot of military,
I've been talking to a lot of military
people that listen to the podcast spouses
and service members and so yeah,
guess what?
Give your service member some room to
form those bonds to be dedicated to that
job because they are truly doing
it for you. They really are.
They're doing it for you. And now
service members, as echo just said,
don't abuse the privilege.
You don't abuse it.
Do what you gotta do.
Be the best you can be at your job,
bond with your brothers in arms,
would that you're going on the
battlefield with whether you're a cop,
whether you're a firefighter,
build those bonds,
but of course don't abuse it and make
sure you take care of your family too.
Yeah,
Jessica,
can you lead those that
don't want to be led?
It's still how?
Hmm.
The beauty of that question
is in its simplicity,
and the answer is
yes and no.
You can't lead them in
the traditional sense.
You have to be indirect.
Again, there's our word.
Do you have to be indirect?
Meaning you can't say, hey,
you need to do that, or hey,
I order you to do that.
You need to be indirect.
And the best way to do that with people
that do not want to be led is to let
them lead.
Put the,
put them
in a leadership role. Say, Hey, you
know what? You're really good at this.
I think you've got a good vision
here. Can you, can you run this,
can you lead this?
And then once they're
in a leadership role,
then you can make suggestions and you
can subtly steer them as they lead.
But a important point is that you actually
have to be ready to let them lead.
You can't just be like,
oh, I want you to run this.
And then all of a sudden you go all
level seven micromanagement on people.
You have to let them lead.
You have to let it go.
Let them go.
Now you do need to make sure
that they're being safe,
you know, or make sure that
they're being profitable.
Make sure that we're not doing anything
illegal or agregious in what they're
doing. But you have to let them lead.
You have to let them make decisions.
And so that, that is my first suggestion
is to put them in a leadership role. Now,
if there's no way to put
them in a leadership role,
then let them lead their little part
of the mission, whatever that is.
Let them tell you how they are
going to do things. And again,
you can make little course
corrections along the way,
but you need to let them lead.
Now,
one of the hardest parts of both
these situations is guess what?
Your Ego,
because guess what?
You want to be the leader.
You are offended by someone that
doesn't want to be. Let me look. Well,
why aren't they listening to me? I am
awesome. I am the leader. I'm in charge.
I outrank them.
Why aren't they listening to me?
All those are little insecurities that
you have about your own leadership
capabilities.
Don't let it happen.
I was never offended by subordinates
that I had that wanted to lead more,
that wanted my job.
I wanted them to want to have my job.
I wanted them to be able to take my
job from me. That's what I wanted.
If they're doing that good,
I can look upwards and outwards and
I can focus on other things. Good.
Come and take my job,
be good enough to take my job.
Okay.
And if I ever said to myself,
I can't believe this guy's trying to
step up and take my job, I realized,
Oh my God,
I'm being insecure.
I need to put my own ego in
check because you know what?
If they can step up and do my job good,
I'll step up and do the next person's job.
So when somebody below you
doesn't want to be led,
let them lead and be happy
that they want to lead.
Give them that leadership.
That's what you do with people
that don't want to be led.
I just thought of a riddle.
What kind of,
actually I didn't think of it. I kind
of got it from Twitter than made her,
made it into a joke. Okay. What,
what kind of stake does Jocko eat?
Ribeye. Flank steak. Oh,
I like it. Can't take credit. I got
there. I like it. Good job. Twitter.
That's awesome. Good, cool. Good
solid question though. Yeah,
that's when you hear a lot. Yeah.
And I say said that obviously Joe,
but that's kind of like fleeting
by way of flank for sure. For sure.
It's like you don't lead them directly
how you would like traditionally or
whatever. You're kind of letting
them lead, but allowing them to lead.
It's the flanking them.
I mean the people that are like this,
these are people that are either
have a big ego or maybe they,
they know more than you.
Maybe they are more,
are more experienced and you maybe they
really do know more than you. Right?
And they're bummed or angry cause the,
you've been promoted above them. Yup.
So now what am I going to do? I'm going
to be a jerk. That's what I'm going to do.
And so,
you know,
I'm not going to support your plan and
I'm not going to do what you tell me to
do and I'm gonna have my own way of doing
things. That's what's going to happen.
So don't let that happen. All you
gotta do is say, Hey, listen man,
I really respect what you've done.
You've been doing,
you've been doing this longer than
I have. You know, what can you,
can you run with this? Can you plan this?
Can you execute this? That'd be awesome.
And then they go, oh, okay,
Yup. Now do they think, oh,
that's right. He's an idiot.
He doesn't know what he's doing. No, not
wanting to do it right now, when you say,
hey,
you have more experience than me,
I would really like you to lead this
instead of me. How's that sound?
You can only pull that off if you're
secure in your own leadership.
It's a way it works.
Interesting. Flank him. Point blank style.
At least.
Next question,
Jocko.
Podcast listeners and Twitter followers.
No,
you're before five daily,
meaning you're up before five a workout
essentially every day and are devoted a
devoted student of Jujitsu.
Okay.
What relationship do you see between
physical fitness and empowering the mind
slash wheel when a man commits really
commits to changing as fitness?
What else changes?
Well, you heard Bob Hoffman talk
about this a bunch of tonight is book.
Bob Hoffman wrote the book,
the,
I remember the last war and he
wrote the book how to be strong,
healthy and happy and there's no doubt
that physical fitness is going to help
you in every facet of life, especially
in terms of what you're talking about.
Empowering the mind and the will
working out is a test of will,
right? I mean it is going to see,
can you push yourself harder?
Can you get the last rep? Can you
shave another second off the sprint,
get you lift a little bit heavier.
That's,
that's what working on it is.
It's a test of will and that test of will,
and you've heard me say this before,
starts before the workout starts,
it starts when the alarm goes off.
Can you get out of bed in the morning?
These are all little tests of discipline
and of will and as we've talked about
before, discipline begets more
disciplined. The stronger you get,
the stronger you get
and physical will that it takes to get
through these workouts that it takes to
get out of bed in the morning.
That carries over to mental will so you
can eat better foods so you can get work
done.
So you can control your temper,
you can create things and improve
things and you can be better.
Now, I remember a while
ago speaking of Twitter,
I posted a picture of
early morning workout.
I got done and then I posted a picture
of a little d post surf session and then
I posted a picture of posts,
Jujitsu session and you know,
so these were all like three posts in
a row and someone made some kind of a
comment that was kind
of along the lines of,
okay,
oh, must be rough, right? Must be a
rough life. You know, you're getting up,
you're just surfing and doing Jujitsu.
And an honesty,
when I saw that with someone
wrote that I kind of felt bad.
I kind of felt
okay,
guilty in a way,
because here I am, I'm going surfing
and working out, I'm training Jiu Jitsu,
I'm kind of living the
dream or in fact in my mind,
I actually am living my dream,
doing what I want to do
when I want to do it.
And then there's other people
out there that are grinding,
that are either overseas, that
are in combat, that are working,
that are doing jobs that they don't like.
They're working with people that they
can't stand in a cubicle somewhere,
whatever is that doing in here.
I was almost, I felt like, damn,
I'm rubbing this in people's faces
and I actually felt bad and I was like,
yeah, bag. I can't be doing that again
in someone else on Twitter.
Okay.
Came on the same thread
or whatever and said,
discipline equals freedom.
They quoted me
and they were right.
They made a great point.
The reason I'm able to go surfing and do
Jujitsu and work out and do whatever is
because of discipline throughout my life.
Yeah.
And again,
I'm not making no claims right now
to be the ultimate success story.
I'm certainly not, and I
will tell you this, you know,
I live in a great place right now.
There was a time where my wife and
I wanted to live down by the beach.
We bought a house down by the beach,
uh,
dump that was barely livable
and it was 850 square feet.
And we had three kids in there and
my wife and I, our bedroom, our bed,
when you open the front door to the
house and walked into the living room,
our bed was on the floor right
there for a few years. We were,
we just lived there and now
we live in a great house,
but I have to remind people like,
you know what,
there was a time where I just was sucking
it up and living on navy pay and we
squeezed into this house and borrowed a
bunch of bunny and lived on the floor in
the living room.
Okay.
But we had that discipline back then.
And then the discipline of eventually
okay
becomes a form of.
And so it wasn't always like this where
I was just chilling in surfing and doing
Jujitsu and playing guitar and whatever,
you know, there was a lot of blood,
sweat and tears along the way. And
I, and, and by the way, the blood,
sweat and tears along the way. I actually
enjoyed. I enjoyed, I wouldn't trade it.
I'm glad that I was putting those
situations to do those things.
And most importantly,
this
is available to anybody that,
that life that you want is out there.
And it might be a few years in the future,
but it's there and you can get to it.
And the path,
the path getting there starts early in
the morning and it ends late at night and
it requires sacrifice and discipline
and it requires force of will.
And that comes at four 30 in the
morning when the alarm goes off,
that's when it comes. So
get up and go get it. And
that's okay.
Why?
And I think that the idea of physical
fitness in powering the mind and the will,
I think that's what happens
when you commit to those things.
I think the rest of your life will reflect
positively on what you've done and go,
guess what? I've been
real lucky to, you know,
I've been very lucky along the way
and I won't, I won't say that, uh,
you know, I made everything
happen myself. I got lucky.
I was blessed in a lot of situations
that had good things happen. I mean,
for instance, the housing market
crashed and I was in the navy.
It didn't matter to me. I mean I had
a couple of houses and I was like, oh,
I didn't even notice there was a housing
market crash until I was buying more
houses and they were cheaper. You
know, it. But it wasn't, that was luck.
Didn't plan that it was might've
been a longterm strategy. Hey,
I want to buy houses.
But you know,
a lot of people got caught upside down
and some rough situations in the housing
market. And I was lucky in the fact
that I hadn't overextended myself again.
Maybe that's partial luck, partial
strategy, but that's a situation. Again,
I'm just trying to point out that I know
I've been lucky and in some of it, um,
but let's make our luck with
some hard work for sure.
Yeah, just you pointing that out
that you got lucky, you know,
and you recognize it. Some people,
a lot of people they don't like,
they don't want to recognize
all the factors. You know,
it's just easy to blame something else
for what did it happen and then blame,
not playing, but take credit yourself
for something that does happen. Good.
You know, so you're, you're over here
recognizing everything kind of the good,
which is party,
your discipline way of being,
um, back to your, your, your
Twitter posts situation. That was,
that was good. That was heavy.
That was good. Right there.
I thought. Um, and I know,
thinking about someone who posted
must be, must be rough, right?
Like a sarcastic yes. Obviously that
was just a fun peanut jerk. Yeah.
Right, right. I don't think so. So let's
get that out of the way. Yeah. And,
and if he, you actually in a, in a good
way, some people might be like, Hey,
I worked for this stuff.
Don't say that, you know,
take it the wrong way or whatever.
But you didn't,
you took it in the opposite way,
which it says yet again more
about you and your approach.
So that being said, let me add
this little part to it where, um,
when you look at those Twitter posts, like
that Twitter post, right, you have your,
you know, the, the aftermath of
your workout. You know, go look at,
or Instagram, whatever. Look at
every single day of your posts.
Every single day you'll see four 34 wake
up workout for three every single day.
And then step one, step back and
look at all of them all at once.
That's just the clear picture of your
discipline of you're doing it every single
day. Cause like, okay,
I understand I can wake up at four 34
tomorrow if I want to and I'll get a
workout in and I'll be like, look at
me, I'm Jocko and then go surfing.
Go do Jujitsu and eat plank stick.
But if you expect me to do that every
single day and I'm not used to it and,
and I do it that same a lot more,
and you do that. So there's your
picture. That's what it is. Of course.
Don't focus on just that
little narrow view of, Ooh,
how cool it was that he got to do,
do you do to surf all day cruise,
look at the big picture and that
picture just like I used to.
Disability equals freedom. There it
is. There's your picture right there.
Right there on Twitter.
Yeah, that was cool. That was cool.
It's somebody actually had to point that
out to me when I read it. I was like,
damn they,
they're making it very good point.
Yeah. Yeah, but man, that's like
the perfect example in my opinion,
that discipline equals freedom.
It's like within that picture of freedom,
all you see is discipline all over it.
Starting with the four 34 in the morning.
And you know, I tell Ya, if I would have
had more discipline throughout my life,
I'd be in an even better
situation than I am right now.
Like I look back and Saint Man, what
did I do this for? What I do that for?
And that's one thing that as now when
people talk to me and ask me questions,
I'm trying to tell him what mistakes
I made. Things that I did wrong,
things that I did that were stupid
so that they can say, oh, okay,
because the opportunities are out there.
You know,
the opportunities are out there to
make good things happen in your life,
but you're going to have,
they're not gonna,
they're not gonna show up
at your doorstep. They're
not coming to your doorstep.
I'm gonna go ahead and tell
everybody that right now.
You have to go out and
make of them happen.
You have to go out and take them because
they're not going to come knocking on
your door. The good deals not
coming to your door, not happen.
It's so crazy how obvious that sounds.
You know that other than like you saying
that, I'm not going to be like, Hey,
I never realized that. I thought
they were going come to my doorstep.
But it's almost like most people,
I don't say most people,
but it's almost like people don't really
understand that that's true because you
have like people who watch TV,
like if you can't remember last,
remember that. I never watched it.
I watched a few episodes,
but I remember people were just really
into that and they're like talking about
loss and the characters because that
was a confusing shows. Why use that? Um,
and they're talking about this like they
know all the details and they're trying
to figure this out and it over
like seasons upon seasons of loss.
And they know that like,
Bro,
you know what you could have been doing
with all that mental energy and the time
that it takes to watch all this.
So you could have been doing a lot.
And that last example is just one of
many examples of what we all do. I think,
well it's very fitting place called lost
cause you lost a bunch of time and a
bunch of opportunity in your life.
I mean there's things that can be
so inspiring. I guess some artwork,
there were some art form or some film or
movie or show that can be so inspiring
to you. But if it's not
inspiring to you, it's not,
it's not forcing you to get out and make
something more of yourself or create
something more than,
it's probably not worth your
while to be quite honest with you.
Right. And, and again,
the, the whole, you know,
last situation. I mean if that,
hey, everyone's different. I know,
but when you're watching TV, which
is just, I think a huge one that,
that people waste their time on.
I mean,
I can get some inspiration from TV
with cinema stuff because I'm in video.
But I think that I would argue that
that's not why most people watch TV.
That's not why they're watching.
Uh, keeping up with the Kardashians.
I'll tell you that.
So I'm not familiar with this.
It's a show on TV nonetheless.
Um,
people don't act like that.
That's true.
That Opportunity's not going to
just come knocking on your door.
It goes back to what you're talking about
earlier today. Are you going to let,
are you going to, you only have so much
time. You only have so much time in.
If you miss a workout, if you miss
a moment with your family, if you,
whatever you're missing, is it
worth it? You're letting it go away.
You only got that day is only
going to go buy one time.
You only got one shot at today.
What are you gonna do with it?
Yeah. Do something good. Yeah. It's just,
yeah, it's just so interesting.
Interesting how, again,
this is like nothing new,
you know, but I feel like we're,
a lot of us act like that.
That's simply not true.
And that weird though.
It is because it's such a big, you know,
you have a lot long time on this earth.
If you,
if you just sit back and go day to day,
then wasting a few hours
watching a TV program,
maybe it doesn't seem like a big deal
when you add all those hours up and you
subtract them from the actual
time that you've got here. Man,
don't let it go to waste.
True.
Don't do it.
One of the guys on lost was named Mr
Echo by the way. Thank you. Died though.
I don't know. I wish you wouldn't have
given me that information from my head.
You've wasted space in my head.
I like echo actual,
we'll stick with that then. All
right. Um, I think the last one. Yeah,
I think we got time for one more.
Jocko.
I lost my little brother who died
in a random medical accident.
He was someone that I always looked after.
How do you deal with grief and
loss of men in your command?
Yeah.
Someone asked me a similar
question that the other day.
Some of them along the lines of how going
to be good when you lose a loved one.
And that's definitely a tough question.
And I almost replied, no, it isn't good.
There's nothing good.
Okay.
In death.
And then I started to remember,
okay,
the people I've lost throughout my life,
the memories of them,
the experiences, the fun,
their unique personalities
and it,
everything they'd given me
not only in their life,
but in their death,
what their life taught me and
what they're deaf taught me.
The mark,
the mark.
They had left on me and I realized,
okay,
I realized that even in death,
yeah,
in death there is good.
First of all,
I was lucky to have that person in my
life even if it was only for a short time,
too short of a time,
but at least I got that.
Those unforgettable moments,
those precious moments,
at least I got those and
I got to experience those
times to know all the beauty
of their personality, their
attitude, their outlook on the world.
They were all unique and I'm thankful
for the opportunity that I
had to interact with them,
even if it was just for
a short amount of time.
Pin now comes.
Yeah,
death.
Death is horrible and death is wretched
and death is cool and Def isn't fair
and I don't know why the best people
seem to get taken from us first,
but
the fact is death is inescapable.
Mm.
There is no way out
in the death in that death is part of
life and like the contrast between the
darkness and the light without
death then there is no life.
Then the people that I've lost,
they taught me that.
They taught me how precious life is,
how blessed we are to have every day to
learn and to grow and to laugh and to
live,
to live
to a live every day with purpose and with
passion to wake up in the morning and
be thankful,
thankful for that morning and thankful
for the opportunity to go out into the
world and live
to live for them.
For those that don't have the opportunity
for those that were stolen away
by deaths, cruel. Hamed.
Okay
for them
I will live.
Yeah,
I will cherish their
memory and I will leave.
So
let's cry no more.
Let's mourn no more.
Let's remember.
But let's not dwell instead.
Let's laugh and let's love
and let's embrace and cherish
everything that life is
and every opportunity it gives us
live.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
Remembering the ones we have lost
by embracing the ones we still have.
So Devin out there.
Thank you for embracing us and listening
to what we have to say in supporting
what we are doing.
Echo,
what's the best way to support
the podcast? The best ways,
shop it on it, on
it.com/jocko get 10% off. Um,
and that's the way to support yourself as
well. Supplementation, the good kind. Oh,
we haven't really talked that
much about on it recently,
but I mean in any kind of depth. But
nonetheless, it's dope. Shroom tech,
Alpha, brain warrior bar and
whatever else you get into on there,
you can get,
get really into just to experiencing
the website's really dope anyway,
on a.com/jocko or,
yeah,
when you get any of these books or if
you're interested in getting into these
books that Jucker reviews and you want
to listen to them rather than physically
read them, you can do it, you know, while
you drive or do yard work or whatever. Um,
use audible,
audible.com/jocko you can get 30
days free and get a free download,
whichever one you want. They have
a lot, they have a lot of books.
Get yourself smarter. Yes.
Stop watching TV programs.
Get yourself smarter.
Go to audible.com/jocko Yup.
And support the podcast
while you're doing it. Yup.
We're not gonna run a bunch
of advertisements on here.
We're not going to read a bunch of stuff.
We just need your support.
So just go to audible.com/jocko
and support yourself or uh,
get a shirt if you like them. Discipline
equals freedom, you know. Good one.
Speaking of good ones, the good
ones, there's one that good. Anyway,
go put a chocolate store.com.
See if you like any of these shirts,
get one of those, get to or a
coffee mug or whatever. Um, yeah.
Or if you're in the mood to donate,
which some people have been doing,
which is crazy yet very,
I think we're very grateful for that one.
Hey, hey, donate something, $4
34 cents or whatever. Anyway,
those are the ways and as always,
if you want to continue this conversation
or ask questions or give us feedback,
you can find us on the interwebs on
Twitter.
Echo Charles is at echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
We are also on Facebook and on Instagram.
And you know,
this has been a pretty cool
experience so far in last week,
this little podcasts broke
into the top 20 on Itunes,
which was pretty cool of all podcasts.
And that's kind of crazy to see.
And it's because of you,
because of you out there listening,
reviewing,
telling people to check it out,
spreading the word.
It's you.
You are responsible for all this,
your questions,
your support.
So thank you for joining us in this,
this crazy world we're living in,
for choosing to fight
instead of surrender,
for choosing to bring light into
the world instead of darkness,
for choosing to be
stronger instead of weaker,
for choosing to get better every day,
for choosing to live
every day
by choosing to get up
and get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.